une production du studio sf
mais elle nous sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce combat que nous inviter dati
ci-dessus pêche quentin avec -12 plante
on loue le studio s est le suivant
lequel on enregistre le sans-fil podcast
on note trois espaces un espace original
on a le bout dehors on à l'atelier dans
lequel on se retrouve maintenant la même
qualité audiovisuelle dans tous les
podcasts vous avez un projet de podcasts
vous avez un podcast que vous avez déjà
que vous l'avez un autre niveau vous
venez ici vous pensez seulement à votre
contenu on s'occupe de tout le reste
allez voir plus d'infos au studio est ce
point c'est en daim contents de nos
invités cette semaine on reçoit adamo le
gros béguin en personne et sandrine qui
sur les amis de longue date en fait que
ph rencontre mais bon la belle aventure
des occupations des
brèches mais ça fait longtemps j'ai
prochain que qui ait pas de casse un peu
plus loufoques ouais un peu plus dire y
voit qu'elle ait besoin d'avoir des
oreilles sensibles
s'abstenir qui ait souillé vous qu'on
sait c'est dans l'humour et dans dans
l'allégresse l'allégresse et la
bienveillance mais c'est vraiment le fun
de voir des gosses vraiment plus relax
son sprint bien un jour à tanger pas on
va faire admettre qu'on des histoires
complètement in scène comme lui seul
sait le faire dont nous parlait de
mobiles les bleus qui sont 2 2 a
intéressé par molly on ne se parlait de
adamou que ben en fait on a tous vécu
des départs plus difficile avec la
polémique sur plusieurs choses qu'un
continent le dépoussiérer fait un tir
thérapie ensemble c'était vraiment
vraiment faire si vous êtes débutant
terre vous allez probablement vraiment
vous reconnaître dans plusieurs des
conversations qu'on but pendant de
podcasts parce que vous savez nous ça
nous occupe ces questions donc sans plus
attendre
on va la version commanditaires table de
se rouler sur pattes et
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par mon entreprise pika et le nouveau
produit unique en blanc ce que te tester
donc
goûter auquel
seront les six
bambins s'écoute pas trop c'est juste
quand même savoir le fun mais c'est pas
commun pour se créer
c'est exactement seul objectif parce que
c'est pour les sports d'endurance donc
c'est pour prendre pendant l'effort la
bière 25 g de glucides dont 16 grammes
de dextrine cycliques qui fait que ça ne
tombe pas sur batteur sentait pas tomber
sur quoi exactement ekstrand cycle et de
300 mg de sel rose d'himalaya pour le
sodium donc remplir le soutiennent que
vous perdez à l'aller fort à la sueur
histoire de pouvoir avoir dans
l'intention d'y rester hydraté même
principe avec des électrolytes de
qualité bio un ajout en taurine puis
dernièrement sur le site web du piqueur
points 6 ans j'ai fait un article
lorsque je relate les études qui ont été
faites sur la taurine dans le sport
ya plusieurs plusieurs bénéfices dans la
période notamment la thermorégulation du
corps donc pour être capable d'avoir
moins chaud allez faut
aussi un ancien dissident fait pour que
tu es le stress oxydatif sur les muscles
donc plein plein déni fixe est vraiment
le meilleur
produit que j'ai seulement essayé
beaucoup il ne mange presque pour ma
paroisse mais j'en ai essayé énormément
avant d'arriver à ce c'est vraiment de
la bombe d'autres études ailleurs ajouté
c'est vraiment là vont essayez le vous
serez pas déçus sans filtre 10 pour 10 %
de rabais lors du tchèque hard pour les
obstacles sans filtre donc santé le pr
dise oh une pique à bruxelles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au
chalet trois semaines afin qu'elles
étaient entre les trois manquaient et la
volonté supposée de rester trois
semaines la valise d'un mac os de la
face
on n'est pas le choix de partir ouais 12
mois qu'ils aient pensé le mont blanc
était secret qu'on disait même des
routes balisées
quoi moyens moulin d'alphonse she loves
you do des quais
d'apporter mon voyage à vous tout le
monde finalement étalage à vous parce
qu'on a pensé par javaux pour ce bond de
traverser jarrousse que bush avait fait
c'était mon voyage comme jeter
la baroche
je peux pas me plaindre j'ai fait un
voyage tabac bateau 12 minutes de bateau
les la côte est c'est la main et
most-hid afin que ben ali est là il n'y
avait pas d'alcool y'avait puis c'est
vrai ce n'est le musulman n'y avait pas
d'algues au
salut comprenez tout italie au japon à
la c
tout est allé à m'installer au laos puis
à bord j'avoue et la côte et je déteste
nous ils m'ont fait ils m'ont emmené
faire du surf jamais fait ça de ma vie
dans des places de professionnels il ya
des rats qui avait dit qu'il est parti
trop me suis déchiré puis sa grand-mère
chaussée j'aime paulo moi j'ai peur de
l'eau en fait je ferais sida fois dans
l'eau mais je me suis jamais senti si
penthalaz singapour puis tout le monde
dormait ksa des mouches je dormais bac
avec challenge dans laquelle nous alors
je souffle en soufflant joignent à la
suite elle seule moi je dormais gars
je me suis aussi là pas que c'est tout
le monde rêvait de leur voyage au magot
ce thème alalala lui revient il pleure
j'ai vu le monde 6 ou des travaillants
qui se faisait abuser les épaules de
vous manger mais faut vraiment sorti
temps loin de belles émotions de la côte
est mort du monde s'y prête
un volcan en pleine nuit
c'est ce jose monge sortie de rodez
sortie de route et puis j'avais le style
est mon aventure au 10 km alphand menait
6-3 mais au moins
[Rires]
on peut juste close et la parata de les
délais parce que c'est parce
que toi maintenant c'est le jardin ce
polar d'afrique du free mais c'est jean
raffin maintenant que si tu faisais
n'empiète pas sur la fin d'année non
mais tu as peu et tu vois comprend
pourquoi tu ferais ça maintenant je
serais pas surpris que tu fasses même
temps mes chutes je fais pas ce qu'est
mais on fait quoi on parle de quoi que
si je pars
on s'enligne vers les lycéens go c'est
que si c'est pour un bon pour ferrer la
parenthèse c'est que on drôles ont roulé
que le racket qui dépend seulement de
ses acquis là on est encore un
parenthèse on est bon on n'est pas le 2
litres de lait encore au kenya foc foc
foc
l'epa 12h voyage exprès de la fois où
j'ai craché
sa cracher ou
sur quelqu'un ouais bah oui
oui
c'est bon comme ça dans mon petit était
cette fois qu'une payer pour aller corps
pour aller chez hugo crashy sur you
il demandait de cracher puis de
l'insulté piteux payer pour l'instant à
paris sauf avec tu puisses dans des
cases
voulait seule percée des gueux légale et
que je comprends ok no 2 salariés
pleinement utilisés comprennent rien
avec moi à son âge mais c'est lui qui
amène à l'autre je dis à qui le foot
m'explique pas ce que je combats rien
parce que le mot à ce moment là ils font
preuve cobra se désole tout le monde en
guerre on va finir la parenthèse dit non
l'appareil frontiste
a décroché
ce qu'il a fait trois semaines qu'on
donne l on est parti de ben ali parce
qu'elle vole quand on sert à manger afin
qu'une tremblant
dans un chalet le premier volet de ben
ali à tramelan ben maintenant on ne fait
72 heures de transport on a fait douze
ans de chara pression des fêtes les vols
évidemment jusqu'à qatar passé de 14 à
philadelphie le défi à ottawa
en arrivant à + pallecchi quichotte
notre ère les gens étaient brûlés mor
fall attendant le choc
trois heures dans vam parce qu'il
fallait que caméras c'était la peur
bleue de ph attendent celui de mars on
pourra rien dit pourquoi disent pourquoi
tu attendais le tata steel notamment à 3
aux mains n'a pas savoir pourquoi tu
atteins et non non tout à l'heure de
cette grande boucle avec un stand by
depuis
la vallée de l'elorn et à tremblant au
chalet le toit angevin sera pas la peine
de lire
joseph est incroyable ph j'ai
appris que joannie elle est trop à
l'étroit les trois
là on arrive le mobi alex on n'est pas
ensemble ont fait chambre à part c'est
clairement
gagné chez lui en attendant
je sais que tu es encore
totalement terminée joannie
x 6 x l'après midi pour que les ciels
tiézan quelques minutes quand notamment
en groupe et on dirait qu'il est
tellement que ça a été long avant de se
rendre à ce monsieur quand on pourrait
la décrire cette cendre moi je me suis
mis à me lever le matin j'entends ph
tabarnak tchèque a fait ça et là
j'entends que ce je m'en viens je m
dulay c'est quand même quoi ce genre la
pac pesci avait choisi contre lui sinon
mes jambes jour le frigo le matin bonne
affaire pour pour mettre genre et pour
pour ouvrir le frigo reste il va faire
quoi même jour le frigo lieu du lait qui
ne roule dessus puis on le sait les pays
de l'est en carton pas avec les becs lé
bon avec elle si le petit un carton mène
pas là quelqu'un l'a vu passer pas mal à
quelqu'un chez at t qui l'avait europe
il avait juste fixé de quota décroché il
avait couché d'arafat genre looking
statements économique fait qu'un tarn
c'est qu'il fait ce plat d'amour cette
histoire peut on alors parler après
ensemble fait un peu confirmé que ça
n'ait pas été alex avec qui j'allais
[Rires]
alex j'ai tendance à me rapproche et
jusque stx terol bien ce qui se passe le
lait coule et tout le monde le mot
j'embarque pour nettoyer avec lui le
vénérable classé comme tout est triste
que je nettoie le salariat
a je pense c'est moi qui ai fait ça on
est au taquet même toit les assos
je pense et moi le scam qu'est google
pourquoi
je vais retrouver mon ex m'a
drôlement la maison n'était que j'avais
ou charger les est le monteil puisade
brandon mccarthy kachti retrouver même
dans la finale je t'ai jamais vu les
yeux aussi d un match tellement on était
tout de même la tête
j'adore joinel
baca
la journée que ça s'est terminé j'ai
respiré où je vivais j'étais libre je
t'ai fluide comprend dessus parce qu
avec joanie c'était quand même du texte
était besoin de tisser elle comme un fil
alors sur le public était là avec moi
quand ça finissait juste comme
libérateur
on
peut absolument pas d'autres comtés mais
je ne
sais plus
pour les gens qui ont écouté mon dernier
podcast est bouchée par les chalands
tabelles de roquettes qui avaient raté
rapide si c'était un peu le début du
pourquoi
de gorgier vous sentirez pas vous êtes
si des demi dieux eux non si vénéré
j'aime beaucoup utilisé
c'est comme si on était des quelques
courbes et ressuscité
six mois que la route est longue a fait
un bout de chemin
merci je défends mais il est sorti des
bas
mais tout se beau revenir à la haute
tarentaise de crachats et de bénéfices
dans un chaudron mais je me rappelle
plus tu le dois compter sur le seul
podcast cat est venu
c'est trop marquée je m'en suis pas y
avait choisi contre non j'aime bien que
tout est écrit que tu écris ce facebook
y
est allé pour les gens qui écoutent
pas rapide ces gangs où j'arrive sur le
guen 12-24 de bjork et monitrices
facebook et copains mais j'aimerais ça
qui me crachent dessus sur 1 600 kg à 50
pièces par paire de shoes qui osent cujo
aux recteurs que je plus comme l'égard
des jeunes qui part faire des vieilles
exploit exacte d'arrivée 4 peur que je
me suis fait donné 800 bien ça certains
des deux ans où il m'a demandé mes noms
commencent à bourbon pour qui multi pour
choix rise bof bof bof on parle parle
parle jase jase jase se croisent pas
bien de tout de rien la ville qu'est ce
qui fait sa job la bla bla joggi les
espaces que tu es le pwm kg de truffes
et jaurès mirage du
tout gêné si j'osais
tc g c'est à quoi la spag le score qui
est cool jet de le faire payer comme non
fossiles passent moins je prends un gros
mot revient au même
allégis crash cela en face sabots sur
l'arcade sourcilière / / / six
auxiliaires et que ça allait dgo jusque
là figure ansa à quelques ports et
monsieur changement et non pas plus
rouge l'insultent c'est une grosse
marque a reçu
la presse évidemment de cracher sur son
mobilier ses plans dans le souci c'est
le meilleur roche partout 6 nuls à ma
mère
c'est cracher partout c'est grâce à sa
tv sur ses plans dans ces choses
s'éclaircissent à son plancher dans sa
phase de partout je cracherai jamais
christian
[Rires]
le but 24
sur les toilettes sont dans le coin là
bas le jardin salle de bain avant de
rentrer et me dire ça je reste optimiste
dans le chaudron qui raconte et de la
bonne
chère ont fait toute la soirée gipsy la
chaleur au début ça avec la bouche et a
rendu cette chine mais
parce qu'il est authentique
ville nicole tu nous entends ton mac à
proximité et je suis le nikkei je veux
te mettre la caméra ses deux boys puis
raconter l'anecdote que tu m'as comté de
duguay qui est venue au procès
qui veuille ou pas à
la casse la soumission
tu as pris comme un objet inutile mais
le doudou d'alain genre de masque de
un genre de masque de caoutchouc lait
qui couvre toute la face au complet avec
mettons dans le nez deux espèces d pas
aimer vraiment fait qu'une longue le
camp obama et menacer puis qui ou qu'est
la bouche il ya un jardin des petits
espaces un jour de conteneurs la strueth
et le second cycle et un contenant aussi
dépité ben cycliques mais elle masque
puis les deux pike
mais vu que c'est long ça s'envoie
jusque dans ta gorge surtout ce que vit
depuis
pouvoir c'est plus que ça c'est plus
long que ces sources vraiment jeté dans
ta gorge c'est quoi qui est inscrit dans
un conteneur il ya quelqu'un qui s'en va
pisser là dedans le staff arles ça se
remplissent et reliait ta bouche piteux
pas le choix de boire ce stade que si le
bois peut être ou non ce qui arrive
c'est que si tu le bois peut noie dans
le fond jean parce que ça s'envoie dans
les pattes 500 vols directs dans ta
gorge avec soin par franck effect est
obligé de boire la teste veut pas que
noyée dans le fond est restée chez se
sait dans quelles circonstances
un samsung
la personne
en vie
mais maintenant oui c'est sûr
des fois il me fait dire que je fais
l'amour
les grilles talent et c'est fatal pour
parler lui ce qui trippent c'est être
soumis dans un rapport de domination
je
n'osais pas
trop
payés oui mais moi je me demande ce
qu'est ce qui fait que les rennais
je suis pas trop je pense iskra thedan
je sais pas quoi manie minutes mais
pendant qu'ils étaient là il sait pas
quand c'est non c'est pas quand c'est
rien métier mans est sorti avec
malika ménard le money j'ai fait une
prise de soumission est
toutefois soumis
pour lui ce tabernacle
je rappelle tout est un vendeur de wi2wi
croûte et voilà c'était pas que là je
n'ai pas encore
été trouvé facebook
j'ai aucune idée pourquoi j'ai répondu
avec man je veux ta bouche de ses poèmes
acheter jusqu'à in what j'ai besoin de
cash pour qui voyaient dans ma phase que
je te dise place à
lui mais j'ai une bonne série événement
mettant niveau non sérieux c'est vrai
tant au niveau sexuel j'ai une salive
magique jo bats comme sous le label mais
plus
extrêmes extrême lubrifiants à l'aise
que moi ça m'est arrivé une fois dans ma
vie quelqu'un qui me demande de création
en face
je peux détester se manquer tu le fais
tu demandes à halak ouais franchement
dans fastweb qui jappe le chef débuts
chez campos heures je vais doucement
débuté
plus plus plus
[Rires]
maintenant qu'il l'a fait une fois est
ce que c'est quelque chose que tu refais
ray 4 cherche
on est on est là on est au taquet
loin mais c'est pas et je pense qu'ils
en dedans c'est ça c'est que ça sent la
patte kahn a parlé qu'elle aime se
serait crashé d'ariel pis s'ils gagnent
plus de l'aïe elle sera encore plus
tripette cette partie là je le sais pas
ça m'a fait penser à partager sur
instagram on a fait le boulot qu est ce
que j'aurai s'il ya plus le titre de la
yale bon si calme
c'est
moi et moi j'ai plus ces missionnaires
chaleur humaine énergie
clips sur youtube de toi qui explique
comment
[Rires]
c'est une des plus belles scènes de la
saison 2 nord
encore des fois quand ça fait le moyen
[Rires]
mais mais mais un bâton maintenant
combat on revient ce qui cache
on l'espère 7 6 3 c'est fini qu'avec sim
rappelle bien des droits un peu
craintive osiwa arrive qu'ils étaient
plus
d'hommes 5 ratings
dans le
mail à gratter qui fait du bien mais la
banque l'a t avec l'aspect
pas souhaité commenter à créteil aux
hôtesses la fois trop jour de tap le
thème sauf accident non non non non au
sens figuré les un cochon
fait pas mal tu es si elles veulent
fargo ainsi que
prendre au jeu souvent à il serait prêt
non je suis
je le tape thème se jouer j'adore
j'adore jouer est ce que t as rien des
fêtes du léon baisse concerne mois de
mai du roleplay
semaine j'ai le goût de faire ses rangs
qu'est ce que c'est quand même temps que
tu aimerais fort écrit moreau plaza
remettant elle à asseoir tout se
déguisant en avocat puis moi je suis me
déguisant en client puis en une relation
de pouvoir ou est ce que je vois dans
ton bureau
et on revient dans notre rôle enfin que
je drôle
j'aimerais c'est déjà ma blonde et froid
donc mon jeu sam gamegie
monsieur prônons je suis fatigué os
comme ça
si vous n'avez pas eu à la montée je
vais voir désormais
ya pas de sexuel
[Rires]
monter le mont-royal hippie mais ça m'a
jamais traversé l'esprit par exemple
nombre s ouais ok maintenant qu'on en
parle parce que maintenant la seule à
vraiment le petit dirigeant dit non mais
j'essayerai peut-être ce rôle mais
maintenant il ya pas de scénario jeu
quand j'écoute ça m'arrive d'écouter de
la pornographie parfois 10
[Rires]
mai mais il n'y a pas de scénario mais
donc spécialement qui me tourner en fait
que maintenant j'imagine que si mes
temps il quelqu'un vraiment un trip ces
vidéos de genre et
écolières le dit ou de professeur ou de
quoi que ce soit pour allemand que c'est
quelque chose que tu vois recherché mais
c'est pas quelque chose que je cherche
activement cherche quoi maintenant
les recommandations
assez écouté les troupes tout ou mash up
dire que nous sommes trop
oui j'adore l'intro métier il est trop
gentil
mais
ça fallait les troubles le 15 janvier
tapis à lipari vip les incendies j'adore
les êtres aussi mais ça m'a séduit par
le tchèque n a vraiment ça arrive
souvent par exemple de 2,10 quand tu
viens et comme est malaisé de vidéos
chaque
fois que tu fais ton vidéo des collants
opaques réagi regard des sommes brassées
c'est clair maintenant mais ça c'est cia
comme un mime ces genres lapone panne en
cross placé jal bell pizza jacques tu es
pleut dans des formats polythène plus
c'est comme quand tu viens de revenir la
même vidéo psy lambiel pizza décongeler
gallas dans le foot
mais au final parce qu'on a
honte de ce qu'on aime finalement je
sais pas si c'est juste c'est simplement
le fait que
tatin de ton truc au moment où certains
comme le sommet les surboums
espace à ty pas que ta blonde mais non
mais oui quand ils en savent pas ou
alors je me retourne marque nana mais
jusqu'à ou
boom
boom boom boom bang bang bang bang boum
boum boum boum boum
exemple ce que vous avez tout un peu ce
qui a pas fini car c'est celui qui sait
sur une période de 15 mois je vieillis
godard
qaïda
c'est quand même un ton exemple exemple
exemple attendu ses tripes
je comprends ce que tu veux dire c'est
que moi je tourne la page vite en
tabarnak
c'est terminé je commence je suis blonde
a dans la même position pour la course
et ça dépend comment on fait lucide je
pense quand même moi je prends mon temps
j'ai dit non mais vous cacher je fais
l'amour c'est l'acte oui mais moi je
fais la manche belge fait facebook âge
finissant les faits reprochés dès fois
le bétail mais me faisais karakash fini
bête ces jeux récents lasser puis je
peux m'endormir l'intérieur
passionnel le maire
mr
mais là dessus que le phénomène de vivre
de la honte a prévenu s'est documenté
des études la subtile en or à marc coma
a ouai c'est vraiment très commun je
pense surtout aux classes ont évoqué un
règlement gens venir leur sens de la
honte la culpabilité ou genre ces
documents pour être chic et la starlette
en haut un bon pourcentage de monde que
ça leur fait mais non mais c'est pas un
autre métier tu es plus tard ça va j'en
arrive de d'écouter un vidéo pitié
demandé mais je m'éternise pas su
retrouver le bon vidéo en allemand et
espagnol peut peut-être coûte quitte est
coaché kitterman petite souris mutantes
un type de filles dans la vie qui fait
réprimer sa fille dispose pas tout le
temps mais en même temps c'est sûrement
parce que peu de gens d'affaires que je
consommerai qui étonne pas dans
l'optique de
crosse et maintenant je serai pas jalma
serait pas dans mon salon puis à place
d'écouté des offices j'écoute un vidéo
de poing géant et écouter le docteur en
dardant passe qui a fait visiter genre
un condo à un couple j'écoute possible
c'est que c'est pour se calmer ce que
est ce que maintenant vous
c'est comme un peu tard grâce à une
couple de fois sur la même vidéo où tu
es gens dans la foule il faut que vous
retournez gmail au touquet déclassé lui
retourna sur un sujet des classes c'est
quoi les indémodables
l'indémodable qui me suit depuis
depuis le début du cg non j'ai raté sa
première retraite et
oui mais pas pour des raisons d'âge pour
des raisons autres par un
malaise c'est exactement tu parles ouais
ça moi je suis prêt oui mais
c'est pas très important qui met une
vidéo de cette frileux qui demande
jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore ouais
ouais
c'est bien spéciale m
non
m la description
mais c'est en vidéo particulier un vidéo
par un genre de 5,7 à
dubaï cheikh mahmoud mousleh
le jeu de dire à table en mettant le
tout le jul rôle de gamme ma belle mère
je pense que j'aimerais ça aurait
proposé à qui bat tension aperçue
déjà eu un petit crash sur mettant la
main dans tes amis
absolument finir
assez longtemps dans ma vie sans vidéo
j'ai mis hou l'imagination
ses sauts à l'époque mais dès mardi
ça me rappelle quand j'aurai bien vu la
balle donc c'était accessible sur
internet puis massachusetts pour nous
tous mais absolument absolument j'adore
les j'adore mon pied maintenant je lui
fait des fois j'ai de la misère à plus
tard car elles puissent et comme j'ai
moins le temps aussi le terme à bb sauf
que j'étais ado ado au moins se
trouvaient pas de douches machine
de
maisons de plus absolument la rénove au
complet qui a nettement 6 maisons 1925
mais c'est un ancien chalet tu n'aimes
pas de vieilles maisons c'est un reboot
de pas tarder à farges des fumeurs c'est
une folie nationale surtout savais pas
avant de l'acheter quand tu l'as acheté
un rat la liste de jeux là je lis pas
visiter ses surgelés a acheté sa
l'industrie puis je savais que c'est un
projet puis toute façon c'est encore
vides les prix de maisons étaient faux
jeton jetant un acheteur seul this ma
première maison qui est mon budget est
bâti je voulais pas non plus ma côté
d'un rebond rapide
je fais juste devant ma maison fait que
ça allait un peu plus beaux habits j'ai
acheté ce genre de maison mais en même
temps je voulais apprendre je voulais la
rénover de rased mais j'ai panionos
titre contre austin je vais travailler
manuellement toute ma vie mais de métier
je fais ça ça fait même pas deux ans
faut-il l'arrêt non c'est pas comme un
métier précis genre et électriciens
plombiers ou mon ou charpentier c'est
comme tu touches à
[ __ ] avec du vieux puits est patent de
patin puis
et cote ccc de la job à chris pine il ya
des journées je décourage oui ça
m'arrive souvent hier soir le dj boudj
fait je fais de mon bar puis mon prono
avec je travaille marque lui ça fait 15
ans qu'il fait sur piste une machine
puis que j'ai rencontrés dans mes
émissions de renault puis il me donne
des feedbacks il vient me voir et me
donne t il vient boire on y ressent mais
toujours le métier des fois il vient
voir la job que je fais depuis hier soir
est destinée avec une section pour me
donner un coup de main pour finaliser ma
salle de bain le fama plomberie de
douche finalement qu'à y est arrivé il
s'est rendu compte que quelque chose que
j'avais faites est complètement accro tu
comprennes on fait les iai effet
l'humour je pensais mais je pensais me
rapprocher fière d'avoir une douche tout
d'abord une salle de bain finalement il
a fallu tout des phrases que j'avais
fait du crash test ultime mais pas
insulter khimki je n'ai forcé après
mouche tabarnak ses pilotes à fait comme
et trois semaines j'ai pas de douche 1
lui aime mon job et a marqué un but à 4
minutes de chine où vais-je me laver les
pieds des fois je me lâche et kim bd foi
de ces jeunes gens selon leur
année blanche parfois j'aurais fait
paraît pas fait j'avais pas chez la
maison dans mon entourage ses bijoux
j'ai plein d'autres gens qui me donnent
un coup de main mais c'est ce garçon
j'ai vécu se jeta
tabarnak
mon mur est parce que la forme à ma mère
ma douche et sur un mur extérieur si
mythique les murs de ma maison j'ai des
faits photos de stars face au complet
sont ou crocheter maintenant il ya des
motifs a accepté que son vote à maison
c'est de la restauration plus que de
l'aréna en est ma maison il refait le
japon laisse à ses fans je fasse mais
c'est un beau projet puis je vois le
fenêtre sans être parfait mais c'est
maintenant comme un mot de saumur
l'homme étant de haut en bas siedo même
site un petit peu et clean et vers
l'avant black les tablets apparaître un
peu mes tirs mur de chance notre temps
christ apparaît former un mur de douche
si le mur est un peu de monde mais après
ça quand ils vont être dans la douche
puis 30 à céramique de côté comme ça
avoir une céramique va partir mais ton à
0 à eau finalement benoît tactique était
de l'aptitude au large de même puis en
automne tulle puis en battant neutre ou
à même place mais ça marche pas dessus
comprennent toujours fait mon mur
extérieur qui était pourri la scène de
douche couler cela fait chromé j'ai en
fait je lis rebaptise leurs bottes telle
qu'elle fait qui penche un peu de même
par en avant mais là j'avais ma bosse de
douch avait montré une douche schmid est
bon dit me mo tout autour de tubes
finalement câline de binh fait d'école
de photos je défends c'est qu'il ya au
lieu d'avancer mais je me suis juste
ramener même place enfin fait que c'est
ce que je vis a pas mal tout tenté j'ai
suggéré sur le pire c'est que c'est
parce que tu fais ça dans ta vie c'est à
john mara du maton tarifs suivront la
jad vite je l'habitant même temps
effectif jeudi les boîtes partout dans
maison j'ai dit c'est super fun pour la
douche chez vous mais
je me suis mise mais je tape m au dessus
il faut mettre une cuve puis je me lève
à débarbouillette
[Musique]
affiché postulat 4 pts a pas d'eau qui
coule dessus partir le savons que si ton
corps qui n'était pas régulièrement
d'annoncer plusieurs ratages l'autre
d'afrique 20 salles de bains et puis moi
si tout cela bouge
police de phone mais c'est toi c'est toi
mais que je finisse ma maison j'ai
appris à ma ba ouais c'est ça puis on
est parti d'une crosse est une
rénovation de maison ja drancy hassen ne
change évidemment aucun sens je pense le
coupé les humains ont aussi j'avais 10
ans les deux vous êtes dans l'immobilier
maintenant je suis revenu avant
tout et le gorille chacun investi
delgado des lots des
nouvelles le silex aujourd'hui j'ai fait
louer mes deux derniers logements qui
était qui reste et je souhaite lui
aujourd'hui on les a affiché il ya deux
jours on de l'ouémé m'a dit et un
effluent sa loi mais j'ai prévu ans et
grand chose je dirais que j'ai influencé
pour le premier j'ai fait un striptease
puis mais je te dirais que en allemagne
honnêtement si vous avez demain puis
vous êtes bien d'en garder le parce que
c'est rendu fou mais les prix ça
continue je suis propriétaire je sais
que pour moi c'est correct comme je
regarde plus comme un bon vin ça fait
partie des
primes est plus au passé moi j'aimais au
prix du marché ouais mais qu'un que je
peux vous montrer que quand le gros
travail en amont du genre à qui on
pourrait mettre sa tête a tellement bas
mille trois cent cinquante pièces
c'est chouette et était pas si le
plateau le salon gamescom caisse c'est
charmant petit vincent se marient mais
ces sites il sema par écrit son
classement bordeaux c'est vrai elles
sont toutes rénovées c'est tout frais
tout en
950 aucun doute qu'il ya internet les
médias mais qui travaille chez des
familles parce que le couple au complet
travail qui sont pas capables de se
payer un logement ce moment c'est tough
le pendu deux secondes le même 350 le
loto rien n'est
pas présente en même temps
[Rires]
que je voudrais c'est que orange au club
garder vos logements 26 que je dis ça je
dis rien c'est je veux que vous voulez
le maître mot de la rénovation non c'est
ça tu vois ça c'est la foi qui était qui
me faisait tellement parents à consulter
on a acheté le bloc de 2-9 x ionisants
j'ai pas rien n'a fonctionné j'ai payé
le dude avant de mettre un clou le temps
avant de mettre une fois qu une vis dans
tout mon crise de blocs ça me coûtait
6000 pour payer le monde tout le monde
j'en ai payé des années de loyer seront
exonérés des panels
pour ce que moi selon moi matières comme
les personnes qui sont parties n'étaient
pas
[Musique]
trouvé de quoi lasser tout ce qui fait
ça se passe tu sais qui sur le long
terme et
le réinvestissement au final c'est dans
le fond la seconde nous mettons là on
vient de finir on vient de toute leur
énergie est peut-être le vient de louer
les journaux dubaï à partir du salon des
beaux arts après cette série évalué par
à la banque peut par la ville parce que
sinon je devrais payer des taxes pour le
choc le swat banques les yvon riva lui
verser ses dires sur un peu cassée si
j'te portel et la ville venu qu'au
niveau ne l'évalué la maison parce que
d'autres la salle afin qu'ils veulent
baudinard au champion merci 4ème
fournissez sur la belle
non mais il s'appelle
laurent boyer d'orgueil ok on tend son
bras d'un match face à st baisse de -21
genou qui va plaire
mais bref tout ça pour ça fait que
d'enfants à partir du moment là je sais
pas si on parlait de ceux où on voulait
parler d'elle sans fumée excès c'est
dans le fond la partie dans le fond le
geste il est beau tout est fait c'est
qu'il a apprécié super évaluer ce par
rapport aux montagnes du sud où le sait
ça ivalu genre la valeur de ton blog
immobilier
parce que moi tu comptes dit tout seul
vous me parlez de reno de refaire ton
blog gérer des des baux de fer évaluées
à ville moi seul j'ai envie de me casser
la tête dans tab7 squames
l'immobilier la hausse est de l'inde du
placement c'est de l'investissement
c'est d'acheter du crypto
même ce matin
jacques tord fota fructifie qui parle
puis l'immobilier si le plus simple cd
ça c'est le jeu comprendra
mais tu es jeune tu mets des efforts
que les chinois c'est un truc de même
assez large et y mettons l'argent que
j'avais deux côtés je m'investis d'un
nouvelle compagnie de suppléments ou est
ce que c'est juste moi qui quand tu
piques moi mes saisons tu prends ton
argent
directement sauf que c'est pour ça que
la question que je pose en avance t'aime
tu sais rien moi l'autre que sur l'autre
côté maintenant accompagnés de
suppléments sportif si j'adore
140 km 1 40 qu'il entrait
j'entends
je réponds à la question super
simplement c'est juste que ce qui fait
en sorte que je fais
ce que j'aime c'est que ça marche ouais
ça fonctionne puisque la job que moi
j'ai à faire et enneigées des
partenaires je me suis arrangée pour pas
avoir à faire la job que moi j'aime pas
parce que dans les prêts parce qu'on
fait même la musique josé j'adore la
musique mais les estives but dans
musique que j'aille jour du marketing il
peut à la fois que je déteste qui me
cause d'effets été obligé de fantaisie
pas le choix de faire pour que la
musique fonctionne que je puisse me
payer qu'une abeille mes affaires
l'immobilier à ce moment là disent pas
comme si l'ag un bloc mais je suis pas
une crise de sens mais
c'est que moi je me paye ma retraite en
ce moment je me paye moment mon confort
ma sécurité financière dans 20 30 ans
quand je quitte
mes
expériences affecté bien tu es bien tu
es bien bien entouré de france est peut
être avancer rapidement avec un parc
immobilier pis si ça va c'est en argent
et c'est un fond dans le fond au lieu de
payer c'est des gens qui paient
maintenant mais sait déjà qui paye ton
hypothèque de ce que tu achètes de ce
que tu investis pour acheter dans tes
dents 26 peut traverser le temps de 10
des enfants de moins
soit plus riches atteint grâce grèce que
se lancent dans un voile au travail mais
non mais non je travaille seul et non
parce que je
sentais la façon de faire des jeux
permanents qui se trouve des bons
locataires et des bons à 14
secondes de débours la catégorie te
présente au fascisme et je sais être un
bon propriétaire
avec déjà quatre ans je peux avoir une
compagnie de gestion que gentil black ou
si tout fait juste mettre les gaz 401
glock que les compagnies de gestion qui
s'occupe du ménage l'entretien des
réparations de faire payer loyer de
faire louer de tiges à toute la sphère
au complet ça coûte des sous mais au
final tu mènes attend maintenant on en
est ressorti à 10,7 bercy ce que je
trouve dommage c'est que je pense ou
maintenant la prochaine génération le
jour où le mot qui est un autre comment
ils vont faire je la chantais
épreuve en soi mourir ou aller un salon
de bois
à
la retraite oui mais qui vont s'en aller
de leur maison mettons le marché
c'est plus parce que oui là on est
tellement loin de vancouver toronto
tournée tu dis est ce qu'un focus
montréal jean ni à des années lumières
de loi mais leur prix puis l'on commence
tranquillement à monter seule fois qu'un
problème qui au québec ces crises à la
bombe
mais ça va venir
non mais ça va saillard on peut
imaginer imagine tout les gens qui ont
acheté de l'immobilier cette année genre
a dit aux joueurs prêtés les gens paient
100 milles de plus que la parole de dieu
oui mais les taux d'intérêt sont
vraiment beaux mais je peux pas croire
que toutes ces maisons là qui ont pris
100 mille 125000 de valognes en estimant
qu acheter des maisons cette année nos
gens c'est ça aucun sens je crois que
tout ces gens à l'eau vont perdre 100
avec pièce mais bon non si jamais
ils y ont rattrapé des années outils ou
à la peau mate de sang sur les mains
mais tu sais juste que ça n'a pas plu
l'acavite tout ap ap d'une chope les
gens d'être l'argent là-dedans de
voyager au lieu de
10 le crash est parce que sinon changez
mégawatts d'acheter sa cachette
accueilli comme un engouement avec les
prix augmentent plus laisser comme un
esclave et vous remarqué depuis que ça
augmente et comment que le monde parle
d'acheter ce depuis que le monde savent
que s et chalets maisons les maisons les
maisons propriété propriété je vous le
propriétaire on dit que ça que je
serre les rangs du alors je sache que je
pensais je pense c'est sûr que si tu
avais tant aujourd'hui des amis par les
pâtures qui convainc pas vraiment
ils payent leur appartient
à
tout le festival n'ont pas l'étoffé y
aller à toulouse cité sur l'avion je
vais vous
décevoir
mais je pourrais fermer le dossier des
primes est on le voit la question
titille que dispose sur nous avons est
qu'il avait acheté question je me pose
pour moi en ce sens que j'en reçois
cette
prime est en moi j'ai commencé à cech
qui vivent le groupe de mots si j'ai
commencé je mets de l'argent de côté
depuis que j'ai 20 ans maintenant ça
fait dix ans je me range en coûter plus
cher comme jah crise dans le fond je
fais un beau gage d'un braquage dans un
bon temps pour mettre en cage dans
l'antre quelque chose
comme ça t'es qui mais rien ça le pot de
bon c'était discuter se racheter avec
tables ans jugé seul marlon à fond à un
condo factice mais tombe mais elle a des
super mouches achèterait notre forum
jallet mettons ses pions les prix sont
ainsi
jamais rachetant parce que j'étais dans
un tout
genre dans le bourg voilà où nous
écrivons la paire part au studio dans le
boîtier de quoi gendarmes à avoir la
pépie même même semaine du coup
intéressant tu écris au
genre c'est sur le marché deux jours ils
prennent l'île
font ip 9 dh et au genre la fête n'a que
huit ans plus tard mais
le
chômage est à même de vendre sa maison
ce moment depuis six aussi que j'ai vécu
ici en achetant la mienne c'est que
maintenant ils vont donner maintenant
voir les visites sont cette fin de
semaine c'est ça jamais d'avis avant
c'était passé on a envie de têtes
d'affiché ta maison tu as une visite
entre au congrès mais là c'est comme il
ya tellement monkey qui se pointent leur
nez fait on fait que c'est lui at on le
sait aujourd'hui demain et partant de
patente est clair tout le monde ce point
dans journée puis là ils font pas une
offre d'achat pilbara
le vendeur idiot non je n'aime pas tout
le monde fait une offre d'achat puis à
la fin de la fin de semaine ben ils
prennent les vendeurs prennent l'offre
d'achat qui les intéressent le plus
parce que c'est pas nécessairement le
plus haut ça peut être aussi le plus
facile parce que tu as toi aussi c'est
la rapidité d'affaires les gens qui ont
l'argent n'est pas le type western qui
touche à la fois des 25000 de plus plus
juste prix jours le doute est elle plus
efficace pas d'inspection pas de
garanties légales bon il fait un chèque
leur sport avec d'imposantes on compte
c'est réglé puis fait que peu importe la
façon que les gens disent des choses et
fait kiffer club tu gonfles la loterie
de ta maison met le feu le phoque si tu
sais pas comment l'otan patrouillent au
fait c'est ça qui sait ce qui c'est ça
si je faisais les actions se lance c'est
comme si un peu les âges et les agents
immobiliers avaient mais je les
critiques pas pour ce 0 lyon billon
profiter de cette situation là pour
trouver un moyen de se le demande 'cela
fait la demande mais qu'ils comprennent
ce qu'est ce que c'est pas profité
millions et joseph c'est gagné pour ses
gardiens pour résoudre de faire ce qu'on
veut mais mais normalement tu fais une
offre d'achat maintenant c'est bon je
vous la payer 600 mhz et la maison
qu'ils ont trié demandé il demandait si
139 600 milles bastos et qui nient
demandent 5 9 9 pour finalement kane
quelqu'un ça fait quatorze maisons qui
visitent pioppo parce qu'ils parlent les
argents huileux son maximum la c7 81
puisse déjà mcaleese si je pars si je
paye trop cher
je veux de maison et que dans le monde
il dit aux gars et 7,80 on la veut
vraiment maison est un tout inclus de
toutes parts dans la maison 150000
travail 780 130000 en haut de ce que tu
poses sexy mais à présent futur h 14e
place l'argent c'est le même principe
qu'un peu la location quand elle à 14,6
en ce moment c'est quand même temps j'ai
mon bois et le 17 mon ancien appartement
c'est un appartement magnifique beaucoup
plus beau sur vos genoux faudrait mais
qui reste à parler vu ses gains c'est
magnifique sur un quartier et c'est
quand même un beau quartier selon
longueuil c
ils payent
ils payent comme il dit les
propriétaires exigent augmente de 70 à
cette année c'est un bon job championne
c'est un bon job mais quand l'iss
était trop inquiet il était trop trop la
guerre ou la 14e arianna invoque sa
blonde ainsi à montréal alan un pays
comme londres avance à deux savent plus
trop si vous renouvelez jeudi matin big
au prix que je paye le mieux il se
trouvera prom assortie de deux pour
payer 1003 maths en 2003 à 2,6 de ce
décor est pas un trou et demi c'est déjà
le spi probablement vraiment moins bon
c'est pas tout ça ça va être ça va être
ça va tu revenais 37,5 cher avec tombola
vous chers l'hydro une méthode qui vous
chers
qu'ils partagent à 2,10 prétendu est le
seul pays à travers un petit crise et
roux et demie potro trop beau ça sera
sans moi
j'avais un trou une militaire efficace
et s'est jetée à montréal j'étais un
coin de von goethe à
pointe-saint-charles sa cote et data
systems était bien le steak caractère
innoveris step en europe et tout mais
c'est un minimum ses minuscules mais je
payais d'où sa danseuse brouillard
j'avais fait pour ça non mais quand je
fais ça sur plus capable à 1200
énorme annonce était minuscule et même
deux ça c'est le prix que nous avons
payé a trop la partie s'est mis en grève
c'est beau la granny l'eau il s'est fait
refouler pas de voisins même samoussas
top sait comment parler avec avait
comparé
avec dominique de vivre sutil était venu
si c'est quand même un euro fort qui va
falloir qu'on sorte des centres urbains
à 45 minutes de ce que tu as payé même
que de payer leur est payé comme proche
une maison dans maverick s'est mis à
vendre la semaine passée lille genre 450
me le team j'ai payé genre trop à ça
maintenant les insurgés beaucoup de
rémois phare de dalles mais la maison
est pas mieux que le marché et augmenter
45 minutes rendu proche de montréal et y
ait 300 milles pour une maison qu'il a
fallu 15 mars métatarse et nous
comprenons pas comme s'il y avait un
chien en arrière le nom très subtil cet
intérêt mais je ne retombe pas
c'est
ce mode richelieu
charmer mais en ce moment c'est le
marché
en envoyant des mails de gens que j'aime
aussi visité plaît et me disent oh ouais
mais la dépêche toi parce que c'est une
main puis après ces
années je me sens tout comme chris genre
marchera pas où tu sais que je suis
juste bon ben je vois je veux attendre
l'annoncé qu'a faite affaires
l'attendent il faut que billy le mrj le
bain il faut que tu plonges t'as pas le
choix parce que si tu as presque
pourquoi pas je peux pas battre autour
et jamais trouvé à ce qu'est à la bourse
et à toulon toi tu quoque tempo qui est
écartée pays ça sonne comme un cauchemar
non mais c'est non mais ça va pas
choisir le choix
comme ces gars comme toi + moi jason
maison comme ça à brick mineurs ont fini
par dessus de ghajar et c'est celle où
je peux pas
je te jure même hold up moi je démarre
mon
travail
[Rires]
et tout ça
mais je comprends
raison qui me dit que mon toit comme
c'était arrivé en tout est pourri parce
que jean photo que je refasse le
magazine l'acceptance mais j'ai beaucoup
de gens autour de moi connaissons mais
même à ce
pardon je suis dans l'acceptance parce
que maintenant
sa move le jeu paraît encore
l'hypothèque de cadeaux je serais encore
en train de payer mon 1200 par mois mais
que c'est l'immobilier de quelqu'un
d'autre que je paye sa retraite en ce
moment mais je sens bien le fait que la
fois de dire pythie je dis ce n'est pas
l'argent je veux dire par là c'est du
banc d'un parc de maisons mobiles jeux 6
attentes ça me tentait pas non plus mais
non mais si tu commences peau tu le
feras jamais en fait je vais le marché
va augmenter jusqu'au dessus sinon il va
t'acheter un château d'eygreteau
compatissant des beaux
parents et spécialiste en immobilier
loin de l'ofppt il ya peut-être des gens
qui feraient me contredire la tue
mouches pas majeur de mon enfant mais
c'est sur le plan du blanc parle c'est
parce que ça va continuer mon hôtel
j'attaque là
on est en dessous de lascaux on a un
mauvais problème peut-être notre
génération de vouloir quelque chose qui
est suite à notre goût tu comprends nos
parents qui ont eu leur première maison
plus première affaire le sillon
commandes sur la gênait les générations
avant les autres y avait une mère sa
base à 55 ans dont on est des mercedes à
22 ans qui combat son
nom mais je veux dire on veut rapidement
quelque chose on veut rapidement de luxe
le confort la perfection le mais parce
que le hockey dans léon bucks mais tout
le monde
neuf
fois ce qu'ils mangeaient pas de
mercedes mais
mes
critiques postées aux larges de nos
parents c'était plus facile d'acheter
pour nous
oui mais maintenant je regarde maman qui
a changé de maison cette fois
aujourd'hui à une maison incroyable dans
sa rue il ya plein de jeunes de 27 28 30
ans qui ont des maisons que maman s'est
payé à 50,56 compris j'espère que ceux
qui font même je peux marcher ça
montre
que je
suis je suis je si problème le genre de
chalais tu veux mais ce chalet où tu le
trouveras pas aussi si tu plonges pas en
en achetant un moins haute que tu vas
garder 2 1 2 3 1 sur tech faire rénover
selon ton budget peut-être qu'ils vont
des flots du board et le toit
l'isolation des enfants
vont aussi dissous trois fois rénovée du
petit enfant un petit peu ma naissance à
3 4 1 2 sur ta maison l'autre souvent
pour des choses comme je pense que tu
fais ça dévoile ce que tu vas pouvoir
d'achat pour la maison sans vie d'amour
je veux bémol à ce discours là même pas
ce que je peux dire que ce nécessité
c'est maintenant
en ce moment oui je paye l'hypothèque de
quelqu'un d'autre c'est l'argent que je
mets dans ce loyer la mort viendra
jamais mais en même temps en faisant
stephen g achètent quand même quelque
chose c'est là qu'il tient dans la paix
j'achète de pas voir arriver chez nous
puis à avoir un toit qui coule ou un mur
qui est des colonnes en algérie ce
tapage et rien géré il ya quelque chose
qui arrive dans ma porte lorsque j ai
qu'un seul ce que je mets par moi
j'achète ce aussi de ses proches de
l'argent que je m'adapte et qui infecte
et je me dis tu achète la paix psig
cessé ces deux cd audio 2 cc 66 et
d'autres façons de deux façons aussi
devoir maintenant c'est parce qu'on
parlait d'investir de l'argent puis on
est tous tendus assure aujourd'hui et
chalets dans le boa trembler les
décombres a dit non plus faut-il
l'achète
et en ville je vous dis t'as pas de
chien non exactes et pas besoin
nécessairement d'un terrain est
exactement
je me suis juste allé voir une
conseillère financière malade il ya du
monde mais qui peuvent super bien vivre
toute leur crise de jours le taux de
leur ville en avant en étant de 14
absolument c'est pas grave on est frais
parce que nous inscrire les nécessités
de georges des prothèses je faisais mon
chien ce moment le
pardon le fait d'avoir un terrain c'est
incroyable pour lui c'est clair ça c'est
sûr
jeter des milliers de gens s'en foutent
métier moi c'est tous les deux à partir
le g20 besoin
c'est juste mettant mon frère il y en a
pas dans fly avec sa blonde genre ça
fait longtemps qu'ils aient leurs quatre
ou cinq il mise quand même car ils
l'auraient payé sans soin d'eux il paye
je pense pas même pas eu 800 par mois
parce que tu regardais le 12 ans on le
sait fait scientifique lui dans le fond
ça ne coûte rien c'est le gym bascule
salariés c'est rien les cas sans
l'ambiance dans le font pas peur à
personne c'est franchement excellent lui
dans le fond il pleut
c'est lui faisait parfois c'est
d'imaginer quelqu'un qui a acheté une
maison bleue 25 aujourd'hui sa maison
est clair et immédiat m'a dit l'express
gratuit
la raison c'est pas 250 1300 puis
brusquement l'avant d'un million
aujourd'hui jean pierre payer ouais y'a
même pas d'hypothèque a payé par mois 1
mais ils ont tout rénové bonjour y ont
mis tout leur miss jus de bord opinion
réparer la porte et brise au fil de
l'eau qui coulait pas les taux de change
c'est ça
ouais c'est ça mais c'est tu peux aussi
france avec une maison c'est moche marc
changent souvent de maisons jeu 27e moi
j'aime ça déménage rue c'est non mais
non mais que j'aime ce que je sais pas
pourquoi je me suis déménagé j'aime la
nouveauté j'aime mais j'aime déménager
la journée de déménagement c'est pas le
best à bombay j'ai tellement de
déménager je sais que j'ai passé proche
de tout cas ce
que
rapporte
le canard en bon état judith bosse
partout
mais
maintenant il est tombé à penser chantre
h cool cet achat on monte hellman ça se
passait plus j'entendais ni ni ni ni
badié
[Rires]
rien qu'à tomber
arriver là tout
droit
de m'interroger guitariste dst d'avoir
l'impression même que j'en
sois même
si je me souviens on a monté l'étagère
site qui affiche sur le bord de mer afin
jeté sur le banc même l époque qui
permet pas baltique à quelque chose
kadrige est une journée qui est un
semaine le monsieur ben oui les gens qui
nous écoutent les murs qui est que leur
faire gagner nous qui
sait en effet que ce soit avec mes rares
salut bernard salutations bernard adamus
et que
tu as fait une publication sur facebook
enfin des pressions chadrac veut qu'on
parle de ce nom je m'accordais soirée on
peut poster mon gars
c'est pas ces pages est une passoire
c'est ce que j'ai décidé un certain
moment à 24,10 points ça fait deux ans
que la musique tout se sait qu elle un
peu ça allait pas bien plus chaud plus
hippie sur le chat potté même à tourner
et essai sur une étude lancée
sur la mise en face à sam amidon of pain
dans le bain dans d'entente puis la
choriste de covile j'ai trouvé ce chien
pendant deux ans ça m'a fait chier
honnêtement je sais tout en me disant
que possible mais au final dans ce
moment j'ai posé le chien tabac le mans
n'est j'ai fini par en parler écoutez je
regardais le monde qui s'obstinait le
peuple qui se divisent mais dans ce
battle pro bac slovaque sns
je me suis dit même si je crois que je
vais écrire un petit texte qui veut
exprimer comme moi je me sentais en
dedans de moi comme j'avais écrit que
mal est là c'est qu'elle avait fait une
lettre à mon gros becs à la fin de mon
voyage en thaïlande j'avais bien
m'expliquer je parlais comme à quelqu'un
comme cible puis au final c'était juste
je voulais juste mettre des mots pour
les gens qui ont les avocats exprimer
exprimer leur colère et leur frustration
leur dépression l'heure si leur ceux où
pip qu'ils ont tous les moyens que l'on
sait juste de dire haut et fort que le
go ou les informe ses soins ce que ces
gens les émotions varient les autres ils
sont déprimés sont 6 on se sent comme ça
parce qu'ils ont des dimensions exactes
phoque legault c'est ce souci regarde
cette crise de loser mais c'est en même
temps
la gelée verbalisé pour la zone c'était
vraiment un plus mon
élément déclenchant un texte puis j'ai
marché parce que ça faisait longtemps
tarnac jeter htc réseaux sociaux le
ton jeudi l'engagement
mais
quelque chose pour
mon histoire des crèches et des grâces a
foutu pêche
c'était un melon d'eau
voulait pas
ça a été comme un jeudi puis honnêtement
leur tour que j'ai eue de ce d'amour et
de céder le monde qui m'ont poche qui
était un mélange pose qu'on aime ce que
tu fais baba ou du monde qui m'ont dit
merci d'avoir mis des mots sur ce que
j'ai assez d'exemples mais plus
tellement longtemps c'est là que j'ai
réalisé tarnac étaient en phase de
coësmes anita temps je dise de quoi
parce que ça vraiment bien
mon commencé à paniquer
parce que c'est arrivé à peu près d'en
juger fait ce pas longtemps après le la
triste nouvelle de karim ouellet train
factor j'ai comme l'impression que le
monde on fait quand même le simple song
qui fait le tour maintenant un autre nom
jusqu'à réclament a même appelé le
moment mon gars de l'ebm animapp el
khalili et que des shows le ksar d'aït
capote lait sans connaître la musique
encore le cas mais oui je veux faire la
musique c'est tout ce qu'ils on dirait
quand même dans son texte que je t'aime
dépression mais ça a été souhaitée sur
ses sauts mais le fait que jonathan
texte pour pour m pour aider les gens à
mettre des mots là dessus mais j'ai vécu
c'est sa bête je comprends ce que tu
expliques le parfait bouc sens le mais
chris tu vivais depuis
six mois j'étais appelé cette journée là
parce que les teams ou ça m'interpelle
beaucoup d'affaires lille puis s'est
jetée comme forte même si j en ai vécu
des moments à tort j'en ai vécu une
dépression dans ma vie j'en puis je le
vivais ça faisait une coupe de constats
vu une coupe de foi telle était partie
dure alcôves énoncer une coupe de feu
n'aura pas suffi
ce que je pense que le moment où j'ai
connu ça c'était comme un moment où le
talent de yachts et parce que je rêve
jamais des gardes comme exprimer ça de
cette façon nos intérêts dans deux d'une
vision après extérieur
se décrire ce comme je lé fais à ce
moment là c'est là que je me de plus
face à samassa mais comme cas de sa main
comme si on veut en
partie sa grosse groupe satam propulsé
dans l'après crise mais depuis ça va
faire que ça m'a vraiment fait du bien
de fass je pense en fait bien 20 du
monde le pilote et je sais pas s'il est
tellement ils sont comme deux coups par
les médias ce que c'est un beau texte
mais moi j'ai l'impression que
j'avais je me suis à mes parents on est
allé voir file droit la première de
froid cette saisie filou c'est sûr
diffuse depuis mais pas il ya un moment
chaud est ce que j'ai connu
mini crises d'angoissé
c'est parce que je regardais autour de
moi mettons qu'on était selon on sort de
la cinquième vague l'aide si on sort de
semaine si l' on était à l'olympia puis
là c'est sûr d'autres rempli au complet
puis le personnes semblent avoir son
masque à 6 puis en est ainsi dans le
show puis j'en ai si je me suis
complètement sortie du show puis j'ai
commencé à me dire
ça va être tellement tôt six fours
partir le 6 mai ton comme là on voit aux
états unis on voit en chine en ce moment
il ya des sixième bague qui partent puis
comme ça commence à être un peu le
cauchemar en europe mais j'ai regardé
autour de moi je disais mais je m'en
sors pas c'est parce qu'on vient que
certaines armées
pour sur ce que j'avais cette crise
parce que je me disais j'ai entraîné
genre j'ai eu vraiment des palpitations
de faire genre qui n'ont le on dirait
que j'ai peur on dirait que j'ai peur
que ça reparte parce que je pense pas qu
on collectivement on revient dessus là
dessus mais le feeling était était
étrange le des jo dans une comme si de
rien n'était fois que je t'ai avec
autant de monde dans une main tenant
droit fermés ou si proche de tout le
monde qui est mon sang correspondant du
maski et ja il y avait de quoi être
vraiment bizarre et comme ça fait deux
ans qu'on n'a pas vécu ce pelé ce n'est
comme d'un coup on a comme s'ils avaient
pu rien mais c'est ce que je sais moi
personnellement ça m'a fait chier de le
fait que genre on inscrit après deux
simples j'ai comme l'impression que
monsieur on s'en veut d'abord tu vois
moi aussi un peu comme tu faisais un peu
fait chier du monde les peaux vacciner
leurs actionnaires en crise il mettait
dans un coin comme s'il fallait arroser
sa grosse pompe et de pompiers il est
drôle en option les salles sur dame
aussi je me dis je me disais mais
victime d'un système de santé au final
mais ça
faut encore mettre nos mains ouais non
mais je veux dire on aurait pu être on
n'aurait plus à part
deux tiers de capacités seront vains non
parce que c'est ce que parce que
maintenant et le petit
oui oui on était bizarre et brett
dossier à ses deux potes cholet va à des
places aux dates du monde sans qu il y
ait une période à singapour cette courte
période la tête lâche pas juste
avoir des fruits de suite le
poisson n'est pas exposé un stade qui
est loin d'être sûr mais le petit je
pense que comme tu es comme tu disais je
sers confiné je m'attends pas à ce que
je pense et et
aux structures mentales de rechange et
le tout à la faire de peser les pour et
les contre pieds genre essayé de jongler
que ce pilot je pense que ti il s'agit
des banques mettons en ce moment restera
confiné
ça fait plus de mal en pis
mais c'est toujours toujours plus facile
d'en parler car ta personne n'a ton
entourage proche qui touché par se
laisser piquer qu'il ya des problèmes
certes écrit par la comédie le cd rom
etc c'est 'qui ont voulu ils ont voulu
protéger la santé de peut-être jusqu'à
l'épaule estat moi non plus l'un d'eux
peut-être maintenant disons 20 % la
population pour finalement être reine de
bris mais peut-être 80 % de la
population mentalement mais parce que
non mais lyon jeudi à paris qui a pris
cette décision le métier au final c'est
un peu ce qui s'est passé comme il ya
plein de gens qui ont des problèmes
santé mentale à ce moment qu'ils liront
des véhicules et des pressions des
angoisses qui a eu 10 séparation que eu
des familles brisées qui a eu déjà des
entreprises et des entreprises tchèques
se sont arrachés cheveux de sa retraite
pour tous levés vase a fait pour sauver
je pense
qu'il y ait plus c'est la fapil plus
c'est beau jeu ce qui on confie une pile
tu as personnes de moins qui mordent
l'aco vide c'est comme les contrecoups
son du trou et mais dont mcma crise
d'angoissé t'es pas par rapport à ce que
je le comprends très bien mais c'était
plus par rapport à pourquoi
flipper sur un dix cennes aussi
drastiques man c'est parce qu'à derrière
proche sortie en public minsk dans un
resto puis avait des plexiglas autour de
moi piste j'entends un match que ben
khedda 6 puis la deuxième fois deux
semaines plus tard c'est comme s'il y
avait plus rien qui existait maintenant
pourquoi ça faudrait qu'il le bois
l'oubli la table
ici les employés d'endroits publics qui
sont tannés d'achat les le monde non je
te comprend
aussi une affaire qui est qui qui
qu'henri major juste logique ne sais
c'est une société qui malheureuse
puisque époque qui fait le premier
mentalement n'est pas rentable je
voudrais aussi le monde de travail peut
être le monde tout le monde cherche des
employés essentiellement ce soit je
comprends pas moi s'ils sont comme vous
pouvez le pc est fini maintenant le
monde se sont réorientés vers des
travaux
des secteurs qui sont plus stables se
mettant des raisons qui manquent de
monde en restauration ce parce que la
restauration tu te fais ouvrir tu te
fermes sur rue est fermée avec le monde
qui travaille en restauration des sites
d'e mails travaillé chez cosco qui était
ouvert tout au long qui ont des bonnes
positions de travail d'aller travailler
dans un resto qui se fait close et cinq
fois un symbole annoncé que la paix
c'est une folie tu souhaiterais fort
kent est mort jeune 11h30 à parfumer
recensement non c'est un service 24 a
depuis toujours exacte
le monde sont menacées deux années
ce sont la quarantaine qui a eu le monde
se sont
sont restés seuls sont enfermés 1 2 sont
devenus
ces facteurs même aurait pour elle mais
moi je sors presque plus intéressant
maintenant et puis à chaque fois je sors
je pars pour la même journée de crise on
attache compte à mes yeux toujours un
moment dans mon nauphary un
dans ma tête comme un petit moment genre
moi je vais te gère mais je n'oublie
jamais je regarderai oublier regardant
une place fort vraiment d'être loose
totale au centre bell pour la première
et de canadiens sold out
[Musique]
c'est incroyable
j'ai passé parce que moi j'ai été
emprisonné parce que c'est quelqu'un que
j'ai besoin de société mais pas de nous
en parler mais j'ai besoin d'avoir
beaucoup de gens autour de moi l'énergie
que
j'ai trouvé ça incroyable puis
j'essaie on y ont tout fait différemment
mais j'essaie de pas penser à ce que
tout un pan sahel après parce que ça me
prend la main après une crise d'angoissé
me fauche consomme pourquoi il pense et
puis il faut que j'aie vue du membre de
take - la fois choqué en france pour la
soirée
moi j'ai besoin de monde j'ai besoin
social à narrosse quelqu'un qui
fondamentalement de même on est pareil à
un peu là dessus depuis la cabine on
dirait que ça me change les gens ça ma
boule sama tellement bouleversé le fait
que j'étais enfermée dans la mise à
faire passer dans ma petite dame du
genre on album c'est l'accord laisse des
médias passent à la barre j'ai pas de
chose si j'avais
broyer du noir le menace harvey plus
calmes on sait que j'aime plus le monde
j'ai pu le voir du monde ça m'a vraiment
fait se jetaient le goût le plus faute
sociale ça
va se replacer au final peut-être
peut-être que tout ce mal et on n'a pas
le problème peut être dans cinq dix est
comme ça vaut rester dans ma bulle non
mais je sais pas je pense que je pense
moment par les bras parce que peut-être
ça va avoir amené de positif le aussi
sur ce qu'on veut vraiment puisqu'on est
devant toi sur ce que c'est moche 8 mois
20 avant confiance sur les changes tend
un couple hétéro pis j'étais sur un
nuage les hôtes ils donnent du temps que
tu as encore dans note après aux deux
ans d'avoir pitié les festivals puis les
les invitations d'ouvertures de
restaurants
mais c'est ma vie à moi mais tout le
monde la vie a changé mais mou ça m'a
permis de me retrouver put me ressource
évidemment on les ramasse que réellement
me faisait du bien c'était pas
nécessairement d'aller dans le public
puis d'avoir un d'être compris ce que
comprennent ce que je faisais ça me
ramener à découvrir réellement les
choses qui me rend heureuse pour vrai tu
sais si
tu
es dans un milieu qui l'a pas milieu
mais su agen qui est un peu plus
artificiel mais je dirais pas
artificiellement ça se passe à ce procès
je dis rien d'artificiel la casa sports
ça ce procès ont été vives elles ont le
vivais pour lever à moi je le veux un
talent que je me sens que
j'adore les gens spa sur le métier c'est
juste la fête londres est que tout ce
mot un peu en fait monette en crise puis
je pense que c'est vraiment les effets
secondaires sur ma vie professionnelle
qui m'a fait le plus mal c'est et ci
dessus l'aco vie douce et la musique
c'est pas la copie de l'accord et
d'attac tels moins pour le progrès 6
aces que la vérité si un peu de sociétés
ancien policier pas de ce discours est
tenu d'informer le la crise est arrivée
la personne en arrêt par les tabernacles
on aurait juste qu'il avait bon je serai
pas dit pourquoi on n'a rien juste
mourut de quelque chose l'aqsiq féminin
là on est dans une société il faut faire
attention à
ses vrais parents la ville attend
actuellement encore les cités jusqu'en
banlieue
chic c'est très très service mais moi je
m'en fous je m'en fous si ma grand-mère
lakovic parce que ma grand mère est
arrivée elle me plaît lui 80 ans dans
une société où l'époque où la corvette
est arrivée par le poignet ce puis ça
fait partie de la fois qu'une vie
montréal même si je sais que c'est diplo
ce que je dis là monsieur
fortune resort où ce soir fokine quand
son ami le cancer existe
les cavs il existe tout existe je sais
je sais je sais je sais je sais que je
suis pas encore là mais le temps que
j'ai pas marre de mort et qui par l'aco
vite moi c'est vraiment tout les estives
side de ses réflexes que ça lui sur
toute la société qui m'ont fait bien
plus mal qu'ils ont fait bien plus mal
qu'ils montrent qu'ils vont avoir des
répercussions babe longtemps que l'aco
ville elle-même c'est ce que ce soit que
moi qui me fait ch il oui mais oui mais
ma question c'est sûr je sais que c'est
pas la crise pour se rétracter au genre
des poignets la crevette qu'est il
voulait de la sueur et les situations là
puisque l'aco vide engendré comme
restrictions comme conséquence c'est
dessus quitte à affecter aussi que tu
disais tantôt par rapport à ton album
par appel
c'est que
les restrictions qui l'a amené à
faire des shows
exactions de la cabeza mais c'est ça
mais au final tout
s'est aussi les
répercussions que cette affaire mais
métier comme moi dans mon coco c'est un
peu une répercussion sur ma vie
professionnelle parce que l'état
continue c'est en somme ce sens et à la
restauration mais j'ai plein d'amis dans
la stratégie logique
mais mes sens que tout maintenant
sécession l'a75 soleil des réflexions
cet avis de professionnels tous que
trouver bad c'est ce que ça aurait eu la
même réflexion sa vie professionnelle
mais moussa ne pollue la vie
professionnelle puis j'ai quand même eu
les
jeux ce soit en tant que telle city
souffre au moins demain mais ça c'est
sûr ça m'a affecté une vie sociale des
taxes sociales ces deux noms mais c'est
sûr ça m'a affecté à ce niveau là c'est
sûr comme tout le monde mais je dis ça
m'affecter juste une coche de plus cette
année alors le statut des managers
restera artistique aussi c'est c'est
une job artistique aussi si ça fait
partie du concept ben ça fait partie de
tête de toi c'était juste dans ses
toiles effectuant de pouvoir exprimer ne
pas avoir ton taux moyen d'expression
c'est sûr ça nuit oui métier je peux te
mentir que ces supports comme on dit que
c'est facile à des gens moins je m'évade
qu'ange sur le stage ces spécialistes
peuvent pas vraiment se remettre ses six
appareils avec pas si ça va plus loin
que c'est le fait que je commence mon
esprit - 4 mars tijani inspiré depuis
mon processus créatif le dans le cercle
de la création d'un album ou de warlus
que se fait en musique mais c'est
qu'après que j'ai fini mon album mais
moi je veux performer monkeys album une
fois que j'ai le père forme mais ça fait
l'effet boule de neige de la mort de par
le monde le en allant tourner la ch'tri
prestige t'amuser que je suis dans le
moule
chose en écrit dans un jeu continue t le
cycle en souhaitant un album ton premier
album solo est vraiment
des coups d'épée dans l'eau ouais ça a
été c'est comme si georges assiette
comme si je me mettais
je me mets en position prochain pleut
alentours le
flou
c'est l'eau qui tend à l'aim ait en
images jarre quand je parlais tomber mon
but je pensais que cela allait à un
million de places mme pitesa sandri a
tapé tapé tapé choses finissent plus et
ce mois finir mon idée
inspirée au
top je comprends que je trouve ça
touchant les personnes
contrôlées joke étatique est un bon ami
qui est un musicien aussi j'ai trouvé ça
difficile aussi de sa fille jeudi mais
il s'est en virée vers d'autres choses
qui est ici ici il ya une ferme chez
in-stat cupide des animaux il ya fait
des travaux chez eux il ya vécu
d'autrefois qui l'ont inspiré autrement
balou et s'explique
je me servirai pas fait d'autres
à la crise la cjce
a respiré
ouais mais si je me sens plus léger
c'est de faire ce que je peux avec ce
que j'ai par un but mais après quatre
cinq six mois cet humour le mans des
décombres
c'est là que ça fait de
leur jeunesse parce que je pense pas que
c'est les répercussions de cet avis de
professionnels qui t'ont à tata qui est
juste c'est juste avant de viser ta vie
sociale c'est exactement à vous soit le
support j'ai besoin des jambes pour ça
je te dis je pense pas que c'est à cause
qui était créé mais oui
je sais juste que la musique cela
engendre tout le reste le social si le
seul empire est tout simplement pas été
à commencer à tourner puis 6 août a pas
de pays tchèques soient pas toujours
égaux si je me suis dirigé vendu des
faits diversiers d'un portfolio jeudi
vers
le bas mais non
ça fait pas de sensation assez attends
moi j'ai bougé
expression un coup d'épée dans la louche
a fait
sensation on comprend ce que tu veux
dans ce post pas qu'on comprend pas ce
que tu veux
la vérité c'est juste pour eux c'est
juste pour le sypol pas de casse pour
l'achever show
time est ce que moi je m'ennuie tu sais
comment
on était trop tard
maintenant j'ai juste ça existe encore
et
que tu disais quand je l'écouté quand
même mes propos tout le temps ces mêmes
et j'écoutais même pas le mien
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est mon moyen de comme m6 conserve la
laisse le vainqueur par high tech plus
vieux
on veut que les patates frites sur 17
des rouleaux impériaux exact j'ai fait
j'ai ma blonde m'a fait des rouleaux
mais les rouleaux tabac la sacem
espagnole citant si tu en as tu
passé famille et moi c'est toujours le
droit le droit est toujours peur je sais
pas si vous auriez vous avez un titre
non voici d'un côté oui + puis j'ai
remarqué une avoir men c'est drôle parce
que 15 qu'un juge pure ça le pote
en a donné comme obélix même des tombées
de l'engadine hâtivement sans pression
c'est peut-être ton pâté de lapin
s'ajuste lave
vaisselle un resto patrie du pot de free
suis je maintenant chalet non stop en
congé reviennent un chalet monsieur
chalet gens viennent un chalet elle et
son petit chalet pour essayer un point
qu'un point qu'en mai pour loulou des
chalets
c'est qu'ils soient de leur semble mais
j'allais m'enfermer le bain pour faire
rire le troisième album du groupe big
c'était de l'accord laisse de bons la
musique est incroyable c'est fou
philippines le doom
resteront deux mi temps rien de
pharaonique final de tout l'album jeu
qui toi c'est toi qui fais le mastering
phoenixmiles
clp merci au passage certains pourraient
bien aimé les grossistes et des combats
le mahb longs mais stipuler puis belle
mère m'ont fait des rouleaux du poulet
et du riz frit paix la fâcherie c'est
pour ça que ça sent simple j'ai amené
mon père est en fait ceux pour qui après
seulement je l'amène tout ce que
j'apprends jamais mon agent est furieux
que je suis le maître d'un point puis
c'était dans les derniers jours c'est un
battant c'est pas
regarder le même l'ennui c'est qu'un
matin on a fêté dernier rouleau
faisait partie boulot un matin je vais
arriver là sur milana segal parce qu'un
matin j'ai fait les derniers ou de l'eau
c'est vrai le jeu arrivé à 5h30 ce matin
à 5h30 chez nous le juge l'a appelé j'ai
fait l'amour à ma femme tu as dû
diligente salut salut habitations
c'était bon sur dix les gamins météo
comme
le tapageur et évaluera au fond ça
peut-être moins bon
que tu étais pas préparé à bergues et
affûté rouleau m'a peut-être sans les
petites phrases fusent j'arrivais chez
ici avec cheikh nasrallah mais la vie
hier matin je me souvenais je me lavais
york après ça après son logis chef du
moche alors là je me suis défoncé suis
là chaque erreur c'est sûrement ça va
quand est ce qu'il ya un truc de riches
de russie a tellement on va l'annoncer
saint germain pourrait quand même
pourquoi je me suis un bon ouais mais je
sais par la vénérable binger par l'état
kenneth laval ou non même pas
oui genre comme quick
j'ai fait l'amour ou bien après qu'ils
aient voté l'arrêt
c'était le titre
mais pourrait danser ça en gros lard et
à des prix ok j'ai fait me rouleau au
matin du fils voulait leur rêverie j'ai
apprécié le talent la tête vide et on a
bouffé connais pas je me réveillais
j'étais encore un peu défoncé après ce
j'ai vu j'ai pris trois heures d'ivoire
de ces bandits
de charlevoix de charlevoix jusqu'à chez
nous je d'arriver à un vendredi lui en
prend car en plein trafic selon et
vendredi puis je traduis chinois 5h30 ça
faisait une semaine j'avais pas vu ma
blonde pipe la semaine d'avant que je
l'avais vue étonnant sa semaine parce
que ça fait vraiment longtemps
le sticker et maintenant je t'aime
tellement le tt ma magnifique c'est vrai
mais fait elle a douté mais en tabarnak
project one
shot c'est solide
friture est embarqué dans chantant
touchant très dur depuis ce moment a
lieu salle allende gossens bull
fait l'amour à table en mai car les
s'échelonneraient dans ce cochon je me
fais prendre au jeu
[Rires]
à gratter quelques ratés des piges et
ouvre un sport aussi avec mon corps
at-elle 409 qui pullulent à l'espace
eqart histoire le ce poste alors c'est
vrai
oui j'ai fait un instit serment ou sa
page myspace il vous dit de me classer
leur dit que c'est a commencé à
consommer des six bourgeois
j'adore le moche le moche c'est le bcm
pour sa touffe plus que d'autres
puissent cas d'électeurs selon moi oui
mais c'est de la scène nathan n'ont
découragé je sais que dans ce cas
délicat taïba du moche
alors moi
comparé aux autres
j'ai fait l'erreur quand je te sur
instagram
le best qui domine c'est un
peu
[Musique]
comme la poutre
de la
coca cola
[Musique]
si
les quatre
[Rires]
ans que la codéine c'est un peu
je me suis jamais pris ça m'a laissé
comme un sirop le cas des plus jeunes je
pense à sa playlist à votre
image était défoncée ja mais ces
facteurs parce que j'essaie de parler
que mon match hommes ont été les
marqueurs ont été défoncées puis
la parole même mais on se comprenait
même temps ce genre la fin la plus que
j'ai vécu
c'est la création dans la face pour mal
jouer seule excuse et garder trop pris
place dans les parois de mosquée pour
thème de
ces six comme si
je suis pas je me sens bien je ne sais
juste comme le
mon cerveau est comme ouvrir totalement
je discutais la radio c'est plus ne
peut pas faire un trip de morges payer
le salon donne aux milanais de rachat
d'or je parle à la nature
j'expérimente comme un peu
mais je me braun move jouve des horizons
dans mon cerveau
je ferme les yeux je vois des choses
c'est tout le temps boston magnifique
rien qui ça peut vraiment tourner
vraiment mal mais
jamais arrivée qui aimait tant
mais ces
quatre fois
c'est sûr il faut juste prix
la ligne
sur la manche non non à la nds a pris en
faute en fait deux ans que tout et
initie du monde action avait
fait d'amy est très fort pour commencer
une fois pige hors du commun mais
j'avais pas ressenti grand chose
là on va déjà les mois ph
ma blonde puis une baie de l'époque à
péage et remember that may be
les cvo pigeât
c'était vraiment le fun le tireur serait
un bon souper toutes l'ont fait et ont
bon on fait dessus avec l'aapra une tite
le monde puis on genre sportif sommes
là-bas des bonnes pilotis oph l'avait on
avait une belle 4 d'heineken ne jamais
genre descendu une 15 à 24 ou si
rapidement maintenant subir pendant ce
souhait serait pas bon le
ph qui m by the way ps qui aime ta qui
est un fait d'armes du ccfa rostit
jours ci que des crimes non mais
si ce nom mais mais mais non mais ph la
ph le ton
si on
fait ça pour la première et actuel avec
nous avant que nadal ne gagne mon enfant
dit puis nous on a l'habitude de passer
un peu de ce road trip
de semaine de se mettre au dessus du
boss tu parles de ce fait deux fois de
se donner de lavardens nous pour faire
ça faire réaliser des affaires pour ce
faire des mesures dont le feu de paille
puis adam et havas précise louis
allamèle si je sais mais je ne veux pas
dire les noms des autres et moi j'assume
qu'est ce que je fais mais pas pour les
autres métiers et c'est quelque chose
qu'on fait même quand on est d'un agent
du boss mais le particulièrement on
l'avait fait il ya avait très peu tu
avais vraiment après ça fait du bien
mais puis j'ai l'impression que
cette drogue le août lorsque les mettons
ça baisse des émissions de 10 salles
ouvrent aussi la réception à le recevoir
c'est ça devient constructif
automatiquement taxé comme
témoin dans lego tu es plus tu es plus
dans l'ailé justement la réception
baissé de comprendre ce puits [ __ ] -
l'espèce de le jeu j'en fais attention à
ce que je dis oui tu mets ton
léger chose que je t'ai hizzi que j'ai
jamais dis peut-être que je me trompe
mais j'ai pas le feeling que dans un
autre contexte
serait aussi ouvert aux assurés il ya
des choses que tu m'avais dit un autre
contexte tu me répondit non plus que
transposer quand même pas été autorisé
exact mais des choses que je pourrais te
disait parce que
206 tout est plus souvent fait mouche
des plus grosses semaines
c'était la face et qu'on est 7e pis le
en navette iphone plat magnifique un
ânon il en a fait un nom
philomène le médecin
maintenant 11 ans habitant
saint prime et ses fous pareils passé
mais on y est on y est je veux dire prix
mais on n'est pas pris mon est pris dans
une société avec des nombres d stand up
des choses si c'est plate mais en même
temps c'est magnifique que ce soit des
drogues 6 ou des est-il à fin octobre
demande qui nous permette s'ouvre et
puis d'aller plus loin un creuset plus
qu'à que asti faudrait demande en
victoire pourrait vite il faudrait être
capable de se dire les vraies affaires
sont constamment puis de
ton chat me prend une décision avec sa
blonde t'es pas d'accord tu fermes ta
gueule va se sait pas tout est en forme
et qu'il faut que je prends un exemple
le moins c'est souvent c'est souvent sur
des drogues au site puisque tu es
l'alcool moi je considère la période
drogue y renoncer parce qu on devient
des mauvaises personnes de mauvaise
version de dominique moncomble mais des
drogues dures je veux pas faire la
promotion de ce sommet qui c'est sûr que
ça fait pareil qui vous a fait un tour d
horizon ça permet d'accepter ça permette
d'arc 1,6 à terme est il
faudrait plus la foi dans la vie de tous
les jours des victimes
vraiment mais oui mais c'est ça mais je
pense que défaut de faire
cette fin ça ouvre une porte cet amour
une pop ça te fait te rends compte que
ce sont le existe qui après si tu peux
essayer d accès décent
sincèrement c'est charia trial et c'est
comme du béton si moi j'ai un ami qui
kiffent ou le thé des hôpitaux ya primes
et honda médication pendant longtemps
plaie en prend plus mais l'avons pris
des médications seuil a permis de
comprendre un peu c'était quoi elle est
normale j'étais en guinée m et i
neurones normatif trouver des ne
remercie trouver des trieuses personnes
maintenant il y avait plus besoin d'eux
mais parce qu'il n'abrite et puis j'ai
l'impression qu'ils étaient des femmes
et enfants dans ma bulle c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé dans ma vie à un âge où je
prenais du vivant j'ai pris dix ans
pendant 6 ans 7 ans j'ai décidé
d'arrêter d'en prendre puis maintenant
malveillance ne fait pas parce que
même et c'est vrai ça m'a permis de
mieux comprendre ce que je vivais pas
tant d'être capable de mieux gérer
aujourd'hui sans cette médication
c'est vrai que ça fait
je trouve quand je pense qu'on s'est
rapproché après cette source je pense
qu'on a eu des conversations vous êtes
pour acheter des meilleurs comme des
points mais il y avait des apports qu'on
se disait pas nécessairement mais c'est
vraiment à proche de quelqu'un on parle
de quoi
on parle et qu'il ya en fait un trip de
mdm au pij et
puis finalement
on indique
qu'un brin en consomment des drogues ou
peugeot
ça nous permet de ça nous permet de
dégâts pas de s'ouvrir plus de plus
accepter la critique de plus de deux
enfants qu'on dirait pas normal match
qu'on aurait pas plus souvent dans la
vie tous les jours
quelqu'un sait maintenant adamou mettons
jeu donc on se connaissait je trouvais
qu est très jeune afrique je le pense à
roubaix mettons que
j'ai pas mal je savais que tu avais mais
n'est vraiment me confronter pop m en
même temps c'est pourrait
détention sur cette source source sur
certaines drogues qu'est-ce que tu
permets tu apprends la barre et a dit je
vois tu es blessé je vois tu pas le
blesser je peux tu me permettre de
s'opposer juste comme tu le fais
du bien fait bien
petit tu dis on est déjà proche mais tes
défauts def depuis demande qu'il est
tellement approche que les éloigne
qu'étant un filtre ce que je veux moi
mes parents et les personnes les plus
proches c'est jeudi pendant que je
connais depuis plus longtemps c'est mes
parents ou même mettant ma fille mon
frère et l'isaf actifs immobiliers les
afin que je dirais un gauche croise dans
la rue mais que je dirais pas qu'on fera
pourquoi ça pourrait il faire parce que
tu le connais tellement que tout ce que
ça pourrait y faire je sais pas
changer ça faut changer ça faudrait il
faut changer ça dépend il faut changer
semaine il faut boxer crise y avait
quelqu'un avec qui faut seppi bac techno
l'état reste une bonne exemple en tant
qu'enfant on veut pas décevoir nos
parents puis ont-ils mettant sa main ça
nous arrive de faire les excédents
quelque chose note nettement sa paupière
mais en même temps où j'ai transgressé
cette chute cette chose dont je dis tout
moment où je suis vraiment réellement
tout un moment fait de drogue la patente
chez les expériences sexuelles
si ma fille ça les fait grandir ça l'a
fait grandir votre relation relation
puis ou du moment que j'étais plus
d'avoir mai à fin de la journée
ouais mais je comprends les cas de
figure et dispose de couette
ou toi avec ta mans c'est la relation
mais est-ce que tu est relation avec
tout le monde sait ça c'est une relation
je peux avoir quelqu'un comme un clash
moujalli vous voir david peace est
gagnant je suis d'accord pour la majeure
partie des choses mais ces défauts et
les affaires madoff mémoire de ma mère
c'est une personne qui les a pas caché
que je pourrais dire et je vais le nom
même temps par rapport à l
ouvrir un musée des fleurs à toi
tes expériences négatives c'est quand
même
plus attention
cette dynamique là mais maintenant avec
un ami proche des grimaces leurs épaules
si c'est vrai pourquoi
mes infos comme ça me direz vous avez
vécu ça vous allait
ouvrir un bureau c'est après ce l'un
était ce important mais après ça use une
manière de dire les choses
mais ça c'est une société
comme je disais ça va changer quand j'ai
fait mon texte me déplaît le monde qui y
vivaient la même affaire mondial tommy
lee même moment son dernier stade sucer
fois que le groupe s'est lui c'est sa
façon de
exprimé sa tristesse dans la manière
[Musique]
notre façon de s'exprimer ça des fois ça
peut aussi
nous aider
à faire des choix j'ai déjà une claque
une gifle et gif la
mairie ben on parle
je voyais aller rapidement le jeu on
était en état on avait pris l'alcool
bros pis je sais j'ai essayé d'aider mon
opinion adamo sur des apparences et puis
cliquer sur un point en particulier
pitié d'où on vient fait pas de où on
s'en va mais crise que salle une salle
salle en salle une raison si nous on
vient ça fait partie de pourquoi on est
comme on est aujourd'hui team espace pro
garant du futur mais qui ça fait partie
de pourquoi on est aujourd'hui qui a
d'abord on n'a pas la même en france on
n'a pas la même mais on n'a pas eu le
même support de nos par l on n'a pas eu
le même support de ces jeunes de perdre
son temps par jean deutsch et moi non je
veux pas marqué trop la dame et
tymoshchuk est sur un point qui va
finalement km auxonne tabarnak des
iphone
tarmac mais
il fallait pas j'arrête de parler s'il
voulait se comprenne que
je pouvais comprendre
mais mon raisonnement faisait pas de sa
chance mais ne sais pas si c'était des
fidji au fait comment c'est vrai et
c'est comme on vient pas de la même
place ses pions on n'a pas le même sport
pour moi je viens pas
à dabou ben je t'ai sa grosse crise
d'abord os léger prix des trophées dr
ping top shape
torche et il n'avait pas son premier
rodéo
deux entre autres
mais pourquoi personne ne parle
[Rires]
c'est sûr que
c'est madame qui meurent
dans des rizières mais oui
mais oui c'est ça ben moi je peux se
passe quoi
valons bien mais n'allez jamais attendu
en tant que femme et non l'autre la
baule averti souple et ouverte
en tête n'a partagé dans le fond de jeu
offre un jeu on est acquis à l'émission
de votre podcast
mois
puis comme est-ce que c'est comme c est
ce qu on le sait
et on ne sait pas hachette
n'est pas grave a presque doublé sa part
ce que deux et non mais non mais non
mais ce que j'ai un métier qu'ils
aiment ou trois frenchies à vous
approcher 2 st on apprend que vous
approchez de deux simples
vraiment foraine content d'être là
l'invitation
pour ouvrir le jeu pour m'entraîner mois
avant la rentrée est tellement secrète
mon cerveau était hors jeu que rome
engagement tapera pas de pièces en bois
énormément s'est jetée comme messi tout
temps sur tout le temps ça arrive tu
arrives tu as you qu'elle choisit le
temps les juristes comme un gamin tout
régenter va de soi que quand je connais
pour le cheikh ahmar le sport je me
prenne un jeu de finhan à chaque fois je
sortais de deux sticks 1 des fois c'est
plus fun que dans le foie non merci j'ai
jamais eu de fort de sa sueur du sein
des fois même menace grâce à son calme
sa soul funky et d'autres fois la mehdi
d'athlé fois je finissais stybar est
dépensé
mon chat la manifestation gagne
ou
fait recadrer les gars qu'on a fait pour
des amants qu'on se laisse partir ma
parce qu'on l'avait fait l'autre fois
quand on était venus avec paisiblement
leur fasse on est ou dans 5 et ambigu
journée ou dans 5 ans et vous avant de
vous laisser partir ce que
je pense et haoues qu'on était le 5 1 ou
est ce que vous étiez individuellement
bleus 5 je me suis demandé dernièrement
que j'aspirais pour le futur et puis je
dirais qu'il faut qu'on soit nous avons
dit non mais oui qui reste vo chi mais à
toutes les fois qu'on se demande à quoi
on aspire ont tissé soins professionnels
c convient qu'on vient établir des poids
super mouche moi j'ai moi je pense pas
un carriériste le team là ma profession
c'est un gamin je sais que ce soit le
plus fort possible que j'allais texas
une passion ou pas peu importe je sais
pas je vois tout dans cinq
professionnels même ça me dérange pas
même ou dans cinq ans je me vois est un
papa non mais moi je me vois est un papa
puis je veux être un bon père
les pompiers je veux être un bon père je
veux je veux être un bon un bon tome bon
père de famille je veux et c'est le jeu
me vouent ses cheveux je veux être un
bon ami cédric junior
oui
à la vie il avait
la chair à
canon aux bucks hispanophones mais mais
mais mais mais week-end mais personne
magnifique avec qui sait josé jones et
john mayer extraordinaire mais c'est
même pas par rapport à la personne avec
qui je suis le petit jeu c'est quelque
chose à laquelle j'aspire c'est sûr je
veux puis tout le reste b
savas place et puis sa source que ça se
remet ça je le veux vraiment ça c'est
quelque chose s'ouvre je veux vraiment
je vais être un bon parent jeu
je veux passer le flambeau je veux et je
veux partager mon expérience
on au stade
lefort 33
je n'ai pas de pression
pas vraiment
si on n'est pas vraiment d'horloge
biologique des obligations à un certain
âge pour des enfants mais c'est quelque
chose que je suis prêt à petit puis je
vous dire je le ferai pas que n'importe
qui de team et je suis prêt à sopi c'est
ce jeu juste en dessous un bon maire
bien bon mari et au bain marie ou comme
une ennemie très bons amis
ouais mais bon c'est selon merci d merci
c'est apprécié mais si on veut très fort
c'est plate parce que moi ça ressemble
pourtant c'était comme ben ouais
c'est pour ça que pour ce que même s'il
s'en approcha les directs ou bus savez
castellvi la
simulation
blowjob stepway c'est pas le même lot
jobs déplace la nabo le dépôt des
noms mais
ouais c'est ce qui est plate parce que
le tissu écouter parler chez capa
j'aimerais ça être le pas que mon père
était exceptionnel
malheureusement la maladie a fait en
sorte que bon il est parti trop tôt
m'avoir été ma mère le problème
c'est que je me dis bon il ya moi je
vais essayer de faire ce que j'essaie de
faire en sorte que mon fils fille
rêveuse
puisse
correction pas jouer ou sa collection
voir juste vivre une vie normale peut
être heureux le plus possible ses
jeux concerts que je serais sûrement pas
le meilleur à sa hauteur mais pourquoi
une belle ascension tout ce que j'avais
le parfait cefac mais la personne qui a
besoin de parfum et cliquer juste besoin
d'un port mais parce qu'elle est parfait
fait en sorte que c'est vrai c'était
tard et prétend pas plus longtemps même
s'il ya pas d parfait je veux pour
m'approprier
j'écoutais hier
c'était 2 à bac sur notre système
bancaire c'est ahmed zaïdi en fait y'a
pas besoin de parfait et j'ai besoin de
toi j'ai pu dire ce mot pour mot je
jouais à tous qu un peu ce qui
est parfait aux fenêtres parfait c'est
ce qui rend la chose belle ce serait du
plateau un monde où tout est parfait on
avait à dire il répond
ce serait là tranquille mais bref partie
des gbu qui les a pas difficile
effectivement mais tulmont il faut
passer au par dessus puis juste de cette
expérience la paix de ce viol partager
autrement j'ai envie j'ai de
l'expérience pour
d'espérer qu'ils aient pas vivre tout ce
pur pour seront au même point de bonheur
que je suis que je viens en ce moment
ptc sujets âgés entre les pays avec ma
blonde mathison que ça va faire dix ans
dans un même ensemble l année enlève
l'année
car même si c'est puis j'adore aussi que
je regarde c'est puis je pars je
trouvais la bonne femme l'endettement ma
blonde ces femmes exceptionnelles qui
est la sclérose en plaques d'ailleurs
comme mon père c'est sûr c'est quand
même particulier comme facteur
pige pas si c'est comme un sing des
commandes commence ses connaissances tt
fait que
si ce n'est pas au scanner
j'avoue que pour moi dans ma vie si les
deux personnes les plus à me no joke
c'est ma blonde qui m'ont pas
c'est ce qui est arrivé mais c'est cette
fois que je sais que c'est pas éternelle
non plus et je sais qu'elle serait pas
éternelle
et affaiblissent et c'est cette maladie
dégénérative fax est jugé rassurant face
au plus coriace le sais que mon mon
notre enfant peut se vivre le plus
longtemps possible et longtemps
ehrhoff cessé mais je comprends mais
c'est bon en même temps ben c'est très
beau dans le sens c'est de l'amour
ça c'est sûr dans ses mots versailles -
non c'est ce
symbole mais c'est vrai si on siffle ça
va le podcast je disais les quatre
stades
du cycle menstruel à nicole puis si tu
me disais qu'une semaine avant de partir
avant cette semaine c'est pas mal dans
l'opération maintien je sais j'ai tout
calcul c'est moi je te connais qui
aujourd'hui pas plus je mettais pas cros
et j'ai parié que je gardais ce n'est
pas assuré de tremper le des grandes
banques dans
les
questions qui
m'étaient est ce que ta part de prêtres
fertile mais ça c'est une crainte que je
pense que tout le monde peut avoir
accumulé je me sens
surtout que je tiens maintenant je
regarde le beau frère
sa
moitié tu me manques est sous les eaux
ce qui
passait sur ses pieds
mais vous avez jamais c'est quelque
chose que tu es ce que en ce moment tu
sais qu'un jour où souvent à ces deux
fois que ça marchera pas non maintenant
contacter que j'y ai pensé mais en même
temps le jeune prof au secondaire qui a
marqué notre vie beaucoup la mienne puis
je sais que mark est la tienne au 6
mai mais lui il n'existe pas on a par
exemple à blanc puis
je sais pas si c'est qui
mais la façon qu'ils avaient reçu cet
effort on va faire autre chose j'en veux
avoir d'autres projets on va voyager on
veut
adopter aujourd'hui
si on veut pas charger la
ville mais mais mais mais mais oui j'ai
pas on se l'était jassam j'y pense
beaucoup ça injuste la fête c'est qu'en
jetant un groupe commun m j ai fait un
mort je sais il pleut ça marche pour
justement ma gueule on se permet pas bon
je sais pas je n'y a pas pour l'instant
je n'ai jamais dit que maintenant c'est
là est en relation les gens comme encore
beaucoup de moosch dans son système
ouais je te dis que ce soit seul le tout
réhaussé sperme l'extrême pourrais je
m'en fous parce que peu importe bonne à
prendre
simone a moins besoin non
[Rires]
c'est aussi le fait que ce système a mis
à ma blonde avec si ça aussi je veux un
enfant mais cgt circonstances parfaites
pour tous c'est marrant mais j'ai aussi
les beaux parents que c'est décidé c'est
déjà exceptionnel
talent et j'allais manger une fois le
savez au complet la censure tout
comme un petit centre est noble inc
j'ai de la mise en
jeu
comme la
tienne
devant le coup je
n'ai qu'une hâte grenouille à trois ans
moussavou quoi
se met en place mais
ouais mounard syndicats j'aimerais ce
que ce soit que ça soit fait
non c'est pas longtemps ça fait un an
que mai et celui
en
direct au caire où un de tests suis avec
elles que se cache dans bouge plus
ba ba des fois ça prend des fois elle
aussi de faire entrer prolonge mais
l'histoire que d'un côté c'est pas elle
même n'est pas prêt en fait qu'il
dispute l'autre tu avais dit quelque
chose même pis je vais raconter
l'anecdote parce que je trouve que ça en
dit long sur maintenant la
votre relation est maintenant sur
comment et commence à me semble sain et
comme vous êtes au même sens même
longueur d'onde il y aurait la
conversation est ce que dame me dit tu
es la dernière personne avec qui j'ai
couché en dix ans à julien bonnaire
personnes à qui j'ai couché mais t'es
pas la seule personne à qui je vais
coucher jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à en
arriver là dernière met toutefois pas
seule à elle de qu'elle me reposer me
posez la question
à vous poser des questions tu penses tu
chevalets d'asnières fille avec qui tu
veux coucher tient
sur en voulant que tu dises où il
annonça peu sèchement ça c'est pour ça
que je trouve ça cool de la côte est
avec deux clubs parce que c'était une
discussion honnête et transparent à mdm
au nom non mais si oui
une discussion à led et transparente
mais c'est aussi une question toujours
des questions lose lose très bonne
question piège de la table on te demande
si c'est comme secte et ouais mais c'est
qu'arnaud qu'ils réagiraient choristes
et en moins bien que vient de répéter le
j-10 souhaitait la dernière fille avec
qui je veux coucher ma vie
mais ne sont peut-être pas la seule avec
qui je veux coucher dans ma vie jusqu'à
le jusqu'à la fin
par rapport à lundi c'est quelque chose
que quelqu'un m'ait jamais
la réponse encore plus ta france théâtre
mais la réponse est solide parce que
dans le fond elle assume que genre peu
importe ce qui va se passer dans le
futur vous allez finir à s'emparer cse
exactes sur ce petit garçon pourrait
repartir sur un autre à là dessus le
trim moi
je dirais je veux une relation dans la
vie qui est fusionnel qui est
partnership qui j'espère pas avoir une
relation ouverte pour les jeux mais
j'étais assez intelligent pour savoir
que les attirances sexuelles
je n'en avais
jamais dire jamais une fille qui va me
dire que je suis la seule personne qui
l'excitent comprennent que je suis le
seul gars qui tente le 6 pool ça se peut
pas
c'est parce que s'ils souhaitent
projeter avec quelqu'un pour la vie ce
quasiment impossible que ce moment- leur
pension et qui aura jamais ce que la
jeune fille aurait jamais il n'y aura
jamais de louvois ma mère c'est cet été
que ce site est dans merde et moi je
trouve l'addition est intéressante dans
un début de relation c'est de dire comme
gentil c'est parce que je veux comme
relation ne veux pas qu'on soit pas
convaincu plus voir mais je veux qu'on
soit les deux au courant que genre sasp
également non se lève un matin qu'on
aille en bicouche hayat il faut sans
parler à ce moment là ça arrivera on
aura discussion ouais ça arrivera même
team c'est le ji 30 ans mène de la vie
en reste dans les 155
54 ans est passé près il est plutôt
qu'en partie on le sait pas
optimiser mes temps on peut pas passer
mais tant
que je prends la moyenne des différences
davy avait 50 de gens c'est un bon
parent est mort à 60 ans n'est pas
ressentie mais ça serait d'en avant ce
serait là à 28 ans
ayant ce gars est crise mais n'en reste
plus longs en avant qui est dans
l'ariège de penser qu'ils aient
jamais savoir
plus mais messi se tarit
50 vous avoir un enfant ou du moins
c'est vrai
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je me vois passer ma vie
avec elle mais demain ça peut changer
mais aujourd'hui mes mots pour la vie
avec
d'anciens cas vous serez platanes et stx
on parle de jobs ou non
[Rires]
mais si je vous parle de s'ajuster
clairement il ya plus que cela mais
maintenant on tombe tombe dont ces
jours-ci
projeter loin
- mais mais jusqu'aux 40 km à chaque
jour - jusqu'à demain 6 heures la foire
si c'est la question puis j'écoute un
podcast l'autre fois puis ça m'a fait
réfléchir puis cesser d ultra
marathonien qui parle un truc année en
inde selon un psychologue qui va parler
de ceux qui dit oui mais de quoi tu
coupes alors découvert ou non mais de
quoi
en
courant même pendant cinq heures à
chaque jour de quoi tu trouvera bien que
brest a fait tripler chaumet mais je
suis sûr ça te fait réfléchir a
sacrément - caen - caen - pitau le temps
de réfléchir quand du coup mais je sais
pas mais je pense que moi j'ai vraiment
envie de
les autres personnes à table tous les
bons mais quelque chose j'ai envie de
bâtir sur les choses qui que j'aime ma
vie en ce moment j'ai vraiment la misère
à me projeter vrai j'ai vraiment de la
misère en bois plus tard que ce que
souhaitait pas de boot mais dans un cas
c'est tout cela et où tu habites à
québec ça c'est sûr ben en juillet le
1er juin dans 57 3 mais si dans cinq ans
mène depuis douze jours j'aimerais juste
pouvoir construire du sud pousse plus
juste un jour avoir la pire mais tant
pis je suis comme non mais tu y avoir la
crise avant la
5e
dans
5/7 squevin n'ont en effet plus défi qui
nous a quittés on est fait pour
affronter les défis qui nous sont
offerts le bfr qui ne sont les actions
présentent savoie sport c'est mon ordre
de ben ali puis j'ai pas d'inquiétude
pour tous mes
messages twitter j'espère maintenant
c'est ce que j'espère que dans cinq ans
tout ce sur quoi maintenant j'ai
travaillé plus par pau professionnels
parlent aussi de mes relations je parle
aussi j'espère que ça je veux juste
pouvoir
bénéficier du positif de ces choses là
dessus en place de ces d'avoir
l'impression de perdre identique en
cheval sur une plage puis le
site rempli la g albas et si tu veux tu
peux prendre petit à prendre le moindre
nuage autour de tout ça mais oublie
poquet le poussif et le parena c'est
exact elle a plein la gueule c'est un
magnifique exemple pour samantha
dernières années une chose plate et des
choses qui sont à la fois douces moi je
suis d'accord avec ça j'espère
construire sur son nom cinq prochaines
années puis moi je n'ai pas la perdre
les enfants comme son nom n'en pensons à
toi tu agressés parce que sam
1,31
d'autant que c'est parce que je me
mettant moins avoir un genre je pense
que je préférais la voie avec ben je
pense qu'en fait la décision d'avoir un
enfant serait plus de l'adéquation de
deux personnes dans les airs j'aimerais
ça crée quelque chose avec plus de
personnes puissent se sort pour
l'instant je peins type à lourches pas
une place où rencontrer quelqu'un ou est
ce que je me dirais mettons cette
personne le dax
cédant 1,15 un médecin puis aux autres
comme des gros lose all or not not me
bats gros loser c'est gros loser
merci les boys est venu sur le podcast
ci fut incroyable une dernière question
à voir nicole ah oui c'était 5 1 et
nicole notât soir et adressée à white du
greta soir pour menaces pleuvent
maintenant mais je dois aussi le mien
vient asseoir ma place on a placé
la famille et à moi je te lis mon hockey
qui vézilier s'ouvrir le cas
vous n'avez jamais vous eu la
confirmation que votre permettait oui
oui je lui mets oui mais ça me fait pas
pareil que ça se peut que ça ait changé
à échanger justifie non mais c'est ça se
consomme des choses amis qui te fait des
affaires ise
la région
d'accord
on m'avait entendu
mme nicole ont une relation qui s'est
développée à travers les 60 et 12
podcast j'ai fait sur les ondes de
gameblog est aussi aussi chez les hommes
on écoute et chez eux ils vont chez nous
et semaine des débats des langues m ces
phrases longues et un franglais longueur
et lola tous les rêves mois
catherine ne serait pas contenté
fournier veut danser
les données
[Musique]
du ccfa
c'est griezmann est allumée b à 25
je sais que derrière ses beaux yeux
bleus de binbin des affaires qui se
passe super intelligent et
sur moi mais gentiment à kerviel
je sais pas ouvrir genre moi moi toute
ma vie en fait ça m'a tout à se rassurer
le monde à venir le sujet tout le temps
si j'allais voir des orienteurs est tout
sauf du tout j'ai tout est vraiment
dangereux par rapport à ce mail a duré
un mois depuis que j'ai depuis j'ai
trouvé ma job au studio je pense c'est
vraiment l'élément déclencheur de tout
ce mais je suis stressé par rapport à ce
jeu comme ça m'en apporter une grande
sincérité dans ma tête - 2 comme pas ce
cadre et iis7 jobs le cadre est gelée eu
quasiment par accident des comores au
bon moment et au bon endroit au bon
moment fac à 18 le juge dans un vague de
faire vraiment confiance à la vie ça va
m'amener loge doit-elle
la réponse facile mais je laime de 7 à
10 ans mais c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vraiment ça mon vin fait honnêtement
dans cinq ans je ne suis pas en coupe le
fait que j'ai pas l'appel des enfants
non plus tu es car je sais j'ai 25 ans
je suis pour non c'est encore jeune au
city fait que fait non j'ai pas fait
appel
qui pis j'en ai aucune idée ce qui va se
passer j'en ai aucune idée mais je suis
vraiment confiant je suis à l'aise avec
ça et puis je n'ai pas toujours été ce
qu'ils veulent mais là je suis vraiment
triste et rendu les gens de québec
nicole même la voix sensuelle imminent
mais a nettement
tu
restes au podcast même mais c'est ça
serait con
t'as fait kratos les fans avec 10 12
heures de plus par semaine les dacquois
ont
pensé à ceux mais je pense à ce truc ça
serait plus des conversations juste nous
deux le prouve un compresseur au boudoir
et en fait piller pions
parce que c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressant et aussi un bus doit essayer
le boudoir qui est juste le long et jean
lassalle est présentement qui le studio
original qui est encore combien de pays
d'ailleurs exact c'est vraiment vraiment
bon
mais briller tasty dire ouais ouais je
pense que je pense qu'on s'est arrêté je
pense qu'on commence à n'en pas douter
une section sur quoi et bien en fait ça
serait pramac on analyse bien voir des
trucs qu'on voit maintenant affirme jean
roux et on voudrait faire m blackman
a ses limites il était aux anges après
on voulait faire un épisode aussi sur m
je remets ton des citations préférées
jordan line qui est que qu'on trouve
cool là qui nous parle pierre fait quoi
ce serait ce genre de truc que je pense
c'est malin est ce que vous prenez un
jeu jubault pas toujours mouche rennes
dans les cales c'est pas légal la démo
podcast est pas légal
négoce de titres ou dans la somme g j'ai
retrouvé mon anus mais
je trouve pour son ami non mais je sais
pas vous mais j'ai peur j'ai parlé d'un
espace
qui était celle que tout ce que je fais
parce que la femme de jeter passée à
s'extraire à un moment donné j'avais dit
que j'avais essayé de me rentrer dedans
même si
j'ai essayé j'essaye de donner leur nom
et du logo mais je pense
lambin genre de faire non non ce genre
en plastique leur séjour johanniques
m'avait donné c'est supposé être un truc
sic en laisse comme ap le triangle avec
un club stoppeur au bout avec un
chien mettons savane accroché pour
accrocher un manteau je
vous ai pas tous
j'ai laissé ici je vais me trouver peut
être je ne trouvais pas mon anus jusqu'à
4 maintenant j'ai une théorie je ne vis
que
j'ai réalisé cette semaine j'en ai parlé
au fait d'ailleurs même si bastia mais
là s'arrête en quarts je pense je pense
honnêtement que j'ai pas la décence
mais je pense que j'ai le truc qui en
anglais
pour de vrai mais je pense que j'ai
entendu un gros sur tous ces instants
héros pareil mais je souffre apparemment
un angle matic tant qu un angle
comprennent c'est quoi un bushman est
mal à manger quand je découvre ton sujet
de podcasts
pas qu'elles se complètent dans ton cul
mais non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
parce que si la raison du pourquoi je
suis parce que à toutes les fois bon la
quille entité suis je non non bon là ça
vient que rafik un terme à toutes les
fois que je vais checker porsche barre
tout le temps bob tout en acceptant
karoubi
mais mes deux secondes d'avancé que je
pense que maintenant ton anus ces sommes
étant elle aussi ceux qui pensent que
tout tandis que je sens que tout c'est
dommage non mais je pense qu'il peut
être plus haut que la moyen ne je sais
pas je sais pas mais crise juge pas les
gens dans le but de va je
sais
de quoi je trouverais crise etc est un
anus
un trou tu as deux trous dans le camp ça
ta bouche puis ce qui risque de problème
je le trouve mais c'est ça la banque
celle-ci genre et manucure a déjà pris
ces termes
j'ai essayé j'ai essayé pour vous
je suis estomaqué que d'essayer que tout
est maintenant non
non mais maintenant la femme en afrique
du sud la france n'en est
pas un c'est ça en france s'apprête pas
de casse je m'appelle ce véhicule
maison mais qui
fait non pas tant
parce que en gros le sait mettons
maintenant je fais maintenant que je
pense à une autre ou du corps qui comme
étant tu arrêtes ton les troupiers de
marc et rouillé il existe un et le cpie
bon c'est l'année qui fait en sorte que
se disputeront parle mais le trou de cul
au final c'est juste les profonds que je
faisais des écarts je n'ai pas comme moi
même je sens que je tirais la face c'est
que si tu veux te rentrer quelque chose
là dedans c'est pas juste de trouver le
tout c'est de trouver l'angle
des bas mais je pense que tu es
moche pas mais vous
[Musique]
dirigez comparatif
probablement
est-ce que
c'était lui qui est ce que tout le
contrôle bien
gaulée
quick a pas d'accord c'est une crainte
mais dans le fond mais dans la
fosse mais c'est avec la perte a
peut-être avec la porte sur le taux
va pas être évident en plomberie on
connaissait
ni leur
donner aussi le masturbateur le cadeau
ouais ouais avec un petit truc gueule ou
pas j'en ai mis en plus de l'eau bleutée
amis je trouvais pas le trouble de
la grille de la chaîne
2 août 1 album et on talange
attentats l'on tente à l'ange de route
en bus à manille tu vas tomber sur
quelque chose ouais je sais temps doit
non non je sais ça passe très près ce
qui t'entoure dois te retrouver le reich
mais sinon la prochaine fois que tu fais
caca ava couch
voit sa bouille you
have à 14,10 niveau de la coterie
djebbour n'a pas marqué mais comme c'est
un garçon comme un cas recensés à son
dauphin
metz et c'est pour ça je comprends pas
comment tu le retrouves
je sais pas quoi je plonge les trouverez
mais parce que je t'ai pas loin tout le
temps jamais mais sa rentrée au fait que
je suis chez
moi je pense
tourner autour mais c'est parce qu'en
france il voulait pas de rentrer c'est
est ce si c'est la
rentrée quelque chose le ou des bustes
inconfortable ce qu'on fera au
début ça
si je crachais impulse allied mais
surtout que ma part moi je ne savais
vraiment facteurs et venus williams et
avait pas salée moi je pense qu'on
femmes sont ici et là comme si cette
tamisée durable la ville des lumières ça
en tant qu' on s'occupe de touristes et
de ce fait qu'on a admis sally ouais
c'est vrai j'ai un bon visionnage et un
bon moi je suis sacrément
presse
s'opposer la réponse à la question c'est
quoi
tient pas trouvé ton
tu vas l'avoir trouvé il va là bas on
veut éliminer cette ligue
on
fait confiance à la vie grâce à la vie
fac il arrivera ce qui arrivera dans
cinq ans la vie nous mènerait quelque
parti que ce soit et musicale j'aimerais
j'aimerais sortir un album où c'est en
fait je pense que c'est maintenant moi
toute ma vie j'ai songé beaucoup genre
travailler sur les projets des autres
j'ai beaucoup aider les autres à faire
leur truc c'est autant musique mais tant
que
manager en ce moment tous les podcasts
et celle tech en arrière fait aux règles
c'est tout le monde arrive le seul à un
projet senior bb mémo schiller puis je
pousse jay z a réalisé tout de suite
mais la chicane dans un vague de s'être
un peu plus fermé mes trucs le cea-leti
fait que même si ce sujet rien concret
genre de gars à qui je veux faire ce
genre dans un an mais mais je suis
définitivement plus dans un vague de com
- avancer un peu plus mes propres et mes
propres et rejeté l'idée de narnia je
voudrais en avant puis cité dans la
foule se trouve ou pousser et on se
prendrait pas qu'à ça saigne qu'on
appelle ça et rien qui fait de sens
mettant
ce serait un bon pack assassins de mon
nom mais vous pourrez nicole soit pas de
calais coûteux
je vais inviter ce soir dans le boudoir
c'est un excellent spot pour faire un
parc à 5 cm à 2 ouais c'est vraiment
magnifique c'est pas trop cher en plus
c'est ce qu'ils font là bas cela et on
pourrait le faire la paix avec claudia
là on pourrait le faire de petites
classes équation avec l'original aussi
aussi s'écoulant qui remet pour elle si
ces métiers sommet il ya eu le code
produit justice ici vous déjà voir des
caisses prendra des vacanciers mon code
promo
pour vraiment c'est cool et j'ai eu une
dernière fois pourquoi qu'est ce qui a
fait en sorte que ce l'autre entre
convaincu c'est à cause du podcast extra
fins défi j'en ai un des fils tu es ont
joué avec des conséquences non mais
attends de voir non ben ouais c'était
comment de voir qu'elle m'avait donné en
fait métier dans sexe oral pas ce que
c'est joannie en particulier elle arrête
pas de vanter les bienfaits de l'analyse
des reçus
du plaisir prostatique exemple pour les
hommes c'est parce que les hommes les
hommes exploitent pour à ses succès car
90 on en a tellement parlé en fait un
élément
littéralement donné le dos gavin
justement ces faits que fait jeter comme
si à force d'entendre parler est touchée
comme qui fait semaine et j'ai pu
chauffe-eau je l'essaie mais médium et
aurait pu commencer que ton doigt avant
un pénis en plastique mais maintenant tu
essaieras je bougeais jamais essayé seul
mais
grosse à gauche maintenant je sais tu
vois pas en avant mais ton doigt dans
ton anus tu te rendes juste de tout
homme est en vie car 10e bordeaux venus
tout sépare en avant
ph genre tout fait pour ça j'ai jamais
eu non
non non mais comme légères mais j'ai dit
j'ai dit ça m'est déjà arrivé de me
creuser daverat
sur sky my way mais
j'aimerais essayer parce que des fois je
me lave pendant deux jours le manège que
je m'en fais pas parler
le liberty jusqu'à 1
non non non mais je trouve en bas je
titille la cclat voyou je le sais je sur
le fil je le sens il y est très
clairement le high yield hy pour un
petit d'auchan
d'ailleurs on commence à le sentir mon
menu
mais c'est quand ça dépasse les frites
sur l'eau
sale boulot
ok bah c'est un excellent pas taris deux
coups d'avancé ligue 1
[Rires]
je pense que
je serai et merci à vous attend sur
votre longueuil longueuil guillaume
fournier
les soeurs
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur une pétillante le pétrole vous
abonner pour trop de leur part mais
aussi trop de la mouette trois pièces
par morlaàs par mois et vous avez les
podcasts en avance acquise avec les
premiers de votre groupe d'amis à vous
écouter les podcasts qu'ils allaient
avoir pouvoir avoir une avance quand
vous allez tirer la dynamique entre les
amis tout le temps avons une avance sur
les jobs en avance ou des centres de toi
mais avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que leur chèque le podcast su ni
voulu nous en jazz ou davantage on fait
des encore moins de filtres à préchac
podcast avec là on vient de finir de
tourner le podcast on va en jaser on va
te filer nicole non nicole il est
maintenant évident comme le fit le
travail la place de taza taille est là
mais on jase on parle de conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous